to hello everybody it is Wednesday a
beautiful Wednesday actually
sunny beautiful
not too hot not too cold
you know
uh today is the 27th of September we are
quickly approaching God's day of
Halloween
[Applause]
is the most important day of the year
now that I have two young kids Halloween
is basically the alpha the Omega it is
the only day that matters the big one
and when it's over all they want is for
uh for the next one
I don't know if people without small
kids know Candy is literally currency in
the child world
like candy makes the world go round bro
keep your dollars keep your gold
I want a hundred grand and I'm not
talking about money
those are good by the way 100 Grand or
fire
um underappreciated candy bar
oh hey it's uh Kevin James and the sewer
oh did somebody say Halloween
did all these Kevin James images are
killing me man what why why are they
what is this hey give me a hand I'm
falling in the sewer
I'm Kevin James
that face when oh I know what this is
this is like that face when you put too
much Rosebud on your ass and want to
escape
or I'm trying to retell your story Zach
what when you're uh in a 300 000 Ferrari
and you got Rosebud in your ass and then
you believe like a oil slick on the seat
and you just want to disappear into the
sewer yeah there you go
but I get it man look at this
hey give me a hand dude this shit's
crazy am I the only one 100 Grand is so
heavily unappreciated I agree completely
you got the you got the dried rice for
the crunch
the chocolate and then you hit him with
the regular that caramel filling man
well this picture is not really looking
that appetizing that caramel looks kind
of old looks like ear wax you know why
they do that why would they do this
photo let's get a better photo
anyway
so here we go this
oh the candy to your list
that's a good idea I don't revisit that
so where did 100 Grand shake out
that's what I was curious about because
I think y'all uh we got a beat here it's
not bad all right I'll take that it is
an a tier but
okay
uh F tier Easy Come on Ian why are you
hating bro you know I care about the
hundred grand why are you causing
trouble already this early in the show
I don't get it
um we have no sponsors today so shout
out
to our members
the only sponsors that matter go around
y'all make such a big difference in the
H3 Niche appreciate you all so much uh
we're planning our members Drive soon I
think that'll be next Friday when Ethan
is gonna get drunk everybody
the show's not over till the ambulance
comes can I get a woo
that's what I'm saying I'll hold your
hair girl
blood alcohol levels through the roof
let's go
you know who else likes hundred grand
everybody what oh is that is that right
yeah that's actually from an episode
what's the context of this uh he was
doing a seminar at a business school I
believe and he started he passed out 100
Grands at some point or he used it as
some kind of uh visual cue when giving
his presentation what's that have to do
with me everything
I was just saying I like the candy bar
man yo Kevin James what do you think
about
100 grand
whoa that face when you're asked what do
you think about 100 grand
Kevin James is awesome why is this
happening I don't know I don't know it's
so fun love it it is fun isn't it
um also pleased to announce that this
Friday I've got the details here
[Music]
this Friday for members
we are going to be putting up
the final show of the Year our live show
at the Dolby Theater
the steamies live
oh if you're on Discord we will be
sending an exclusive code
if you are on YouTube you're not in
Discord we'll be sending an exclusive
code via the community tab that's right
don't share it don't share it just for
you if you share it your mind no then we
may not get it
but um it will be available to everybody
else I think what after the weekend
what's the deal probably it was just 24
hours from just 20 so last time they all
sold out but this time
there is a lot more seats true we have
uh
three yeah I know 3 300 seats so it's
quite a it's quite a bit more about a
double
over double so I'm hoping that you know
even if you aren't a member you'll have
a crack three I'm hoping we just sell
them I mean I'm out here acting
like it's given that's a lot of seats
I am I am yeah how much how many tickets
three oh three three right that's
actually pretty cool pretty close that's
pretty close I'll I'll give it to him
so I'm gonna be like
I mean I was really excited with how it
went last time
it sold out so fast I was truly uh
amazed and shocked by that so but
there's a lot more Joe asking uh what
platform uh it will be sold on it's a
Ticketmaster I guess we're we're going
to the bigger than you this is a big boy
venue and they are they got an iron clad
contract but let me say this
Ticketmaster yeah agree
sorry about that guys I know they're
gonna you guys over even though
we've tried not to yeah we've re you
know we've lowered the tickets to uh
free so any of the fees basically just
going to Ticketmaster no that's not true
it's a joke sorry guys for that
oh here's so here's a preview
here's a preview of the venue I told you
guys the Adobe theater is gorgeous
[Music]
wow and uh I was serious about that it's
gonna be wow I feel it stunning yeah
um but yeah it's good I'm super excited
um it's gonna be December 17th at 7 p.m
it's YouTube's hottest night it's
YouTube's hottest night everyone oh we
should show the the banner that cam it
in second and I will say this as well
yeah
that's everybody seems to understand how
I run my business this isn't even the
first time I've done this and it will
not be the last time all the box office
sales will be go to the crew
I will not even be participating in it
wow this man works for us for free
here it is it's YouTube's hottest night
YouTube's hottest night that looks like
me three that's me
that's your host
Jason
[Applause]
will be there I hope Jay will co-host it
I think we would ruin his career though
because he's like
oh like he's on the o list didn't we
read that or like on oprahless yeah yeah
yeah he's not gonna be on the oldest if
he coach host the show yeah definitely
not that's what my teeth could look like
though don't you guys see what I'm
saying uh-huh so yeah you want some
dude
yes yes daddy Kenny
that's me that could be me
don't you guys see that it looked that I
look more handsome like that
I think your teeth are fine but if you
want it I say go for it
I consider it one day big I got that big
billion dollar smile and what about
bleaching my eyes blue
you should definitely do that
bleach my eyes what else have what else
has he done here how do I look like this
guy
[Music]
fat removal
Buckle what about does he have a nose
job or is that natural
I think that's a beauty nose just the
way he has no pores how do I do that
Botox yeah wait Botox removes pores
wrinkles
you just start wearing makeup makeup is
good girl
I see you yeah help me out with that
makeup
yeah that's exciting uh thank you thank
you with peace and love all very excited
about that
all right get your
just to clarify uh because I saw people
asking in the chat
the tickets will go available uh during
the show
so we'll we'll be live and then we will
say we're about to send out the code to
members so everybody's on the same page
so you know you know how this show goes
somewhere around 1 30 2 o'clock-ish
yeah and so tell all your socialist
friends Ethan's splitting the box office
tell him let him know let them know that
I'm one of the good Capital owners
okay there's no there's no Ethan
head-shaped Guillotine out there
you know yeah no way no way there's no
way
you know I couldn't make one big enough
giant Noggin
huge massive dude if I'm getting
Guillotine I feel that Hassan should
also get guillotined I'm sorry why
should he get a password equal
opportunity all right as long as we
agree on that yeah this is America why
not this is America
anyway there it is thank you thank you
um
the tattoo is obviously not happening
today it was meant to happen it's not
we've been over that but I did connect
with somebody
who I'm feeling pretty confident about
yeah I talked to it over with him nice
guy and he's going to be coming to my
house this weekend on Saturday
to do it there and the Comfort security
free of distractions
and get the job done he sent me a um
an example and I liked how it came out
okay it's the picture that I love
and he's basically going to silhouette
it with like a circle around him it kind
of you know close off the edges
let me see if I can find a picture
turns into a circle
I mean I got a really
shitty photo here
because it's like a screenshot of a
video but maybe I'll show you just so
you guys know what I'm talking about
you know
yes
um and a B I guess you're gonna come
film it eh yeah
yeah I think it'd be cool to see uh your
reaction at first but it's gonna be a
while so I'm not sure there's gonna be
like a lot of downtime I was thinking
maybe I could start it off and then
you guys handle the end or something
oh well then I can just have Ila do it
so yeah if he was I mean whatever you
want I'll have Ila do it and you don't
have to waste your time on your weekend
coming out because you know what I mean
forget about it I'm just trying to hang
out dude so well if that's the case then
because you're like I'll do the
beginning and then bail
well I he we were talking I think it's
gonna be like six hours roughly six yeah
you said three to five
well yeah I guess when we were talking
this before he had the final what can I
do with one hand other than you know not
that I want to do that yeah yeah of
someone else
can I play video video games with one
hand not really jack it off what do you
do when you get a tattoo just lay there
listen to music yes
with one hand though yeah
like flappy bird yeah Flappy dunk
is my go-to
yeah I'm Wally masturbating I feel you
kind of get distracted by the tattoo you
won't get bored really do you think the
pain will overtake me yeah and I'm get I
changed the location I'm no longer doing
it here on my shoulder I'll be doing it
here on my forearm oh yeah
eventually he said it's not painful
there I'm just gonna guess is that I
mean it's probably more painful than the
upper shoulder
yeah no it's it's not bad he told me
that
he suggested there and I I came around
to his uh logic because
if you do it here you have to if it's
not like a big ass thing it will look
like
tiny yeah and also you'll never see it
if it's on the outside of your arm if
it's on the inside you'll be able to
look at it I was doing like this I was
like yeah I'm gonna see it right there
like this yeah the images and discard I
really like it based on the image you
sent can you pull it up
oh I can pull it up it was the worst
pain again I've ever felt yeah I love I
think it turned out great and it looks
nice and I'm just so excited I mean I
just love this photo and it's so
precious I mean I just love him so much
so I think this is going to be good and
I'll be right here
it doesn't look a-i-e enough you're not
no top hat no human shoulders where's
the watermark where's the pizzazz
there's no uh audio jungle
this dog is not going to YouTube sexiest
night I'll tell you that
but I I'm actually so excited I I'm I
just
I'm really excited
to memorialize him like that
still hard
but in other news
uh we talk on this show frequently about
the Menace to Society H3 H3 producatons
this man
is causing so much trouble for my life
that I might have to take legal action
look at this
shut up Jeff
so he tweets out Productions just got my
tattoo in honor of Shredder when someone
asks about it I'll get to talk about you
I will always love and miss you buddy I
mean what the bro that you don't
you don't fake a tweet like that
I'm sure many people earnestly liked
that post well and one of them was my
mom she said oh my God what a great job
the tattoo artist did hard to tell how
big it is though
next she likes the top hat maybe she's
being nice was she aware of what was
going on like with the tattoo yeah yeah
she knows that I'm planning to do it
but no clearly not clearly not
um 10 000 likes it has 10 000 likes so
do brick okay so what's do people know
it's a joke like how many what
percentage of people know that's a joke
I'm not gonna lie against me sometimes
it gets me every time yeah it gets me
like
for a second depending on the post I
think half half people think I'm walking
around with a random Yorker with a top
hat on my arm that's crazy
why don't you just start a show hey
Productions I got an idea start your own
podcast
just you know what I mean talk
about yourself damn
I think it could potentially be good
though because I could see haters using
it thinking that it's real getting some
good content out of that they already do
that right they just make up they
don't need Productions to do that bro
well anyway that wasn't even the worst
part of what he did to me
um
I love this photo
I love him
I don't I guess you know
I guess everyone probably feels this way
about their dogs but Shredder was like a
human being to me I don't know how to
describe it
'll be like a telepathic connection
um
so then Donna my mom I just read her
name here I text my mom I says yo mom
hold on okay so let me start with this I
saw this post everyone's like haha Donna
got she got God again so I said this is
me I sent this to her I said Mom you
gotta block this parody account and get
you every time
okay her response is oh he gets me
every time the coin boy 99
I looked it up on YouTube didn't come up
who was coin boy 99 the poster on the
subreddit oh my God
I don't know
okay but that now she takes action
so apparently she blocked me she
responded I know I know I just blocked
him and now people are saying no you
blocked your son because if you go to
her follows
or I guess somebody screenshot it I
don't know if it's here
you see that she still follows him and
not me yeah the question is this
um Donna dusk Twitter let's see if she's
remedied or if she even knows I mean
people have been trying to
point it out to her she follows 71 so
this would be easy
um here this is the screenshot I was
looking for
you can see that's just that's just the
Reddit logo actually
I don't know why that did that what the
yeah
um all right I got it
I don't know why it's doing that
followed by
oh wait it says followed by I guess she
blocked me so it doesn't show that I'm
following her yeah Ethan Klein hosted
the H3 podcast parody
because when you block someone they
unfollow you right right so let's take a
look now block me Dan can you show the
second photo in that post
no because the new Reddit UI
please no I'm kidding it's not a big
deal
verified followers that would be me
right
Donna Donna
it's not your son Donna that's
Productions again
so if I go to verified followers I
should cut it down a bit right
yeah okay
no no she has a ton of followers
following
it's okay
here's everybody on the podcast they got
access
McIntyre repcion
my mom's got a question skeet's gonna be
in here and Electic team YouTube okay
she's pretty high level damn the dodo
the smile I love those animal rescue
vids I bet my cousin who's a pro who's a
wonderful writer Craig leaner and you
guys check him out
wow
shout out on John trapali Shore shout
out thank you Mom for following Paulie
shore of course
oops
oops I'm not on here I feel like that
I'd be at the top probably
um actually let me just go to our
let me check on my phone and see if I'm
blocked I mean let's go Randy rainbow
that's so Donna core disc
how did she block me
but I didn't even tweet to her how did
she block me
here pull that up
like
I sent her a WhatsApp message I didn't
even tweet at her so how is it that she
blocked me
so
yeah yeah
so I'm trying to get her on the phone
today and confront her on why she would
block her own son block me after
everything I've done for her she would
block me and choose products why don't
you adopt him then Donna
you're Donna now Mom
this is what producatons does to a
family
tears it apart
he's so unhinged in DMS too we just had
a shouting match in front of my mom you
know what the Clones like no he's the
fake one he's the fake one she didn't
know her own damn son
she had a gun for some reason
um
she shot me in the face dude and now I
hear the Bell
so she's able to call in a little bit uh
yeah and I sent her the link I was
hoping I think she should be available
any minute now you mentioned she's at a
funeral yeah my funeral she's going from
one funeral to another
[Music]
you know what I mean come on Mom
we've been through so much together
I've known you for 38 years now
38 years and here you are blocking your
son
your beautiful baby boy do you want
Godfather or what after everything I've
done for you mother
you choose Productions over me
can't stand this disrespect I'm okay
[Music]
listen mom
I'm gonna need an explanation
I'm gonna see I I feel like I'm good at
it but then I lose it I'm gonna I'm
gonna need an explanation
that's the best you've done right there
and I'm gonna need explanation bottom
line is you cannot be trusted you can't
be trusted number talkatones not
protectants all right stop get out of
this
bottom line is you cannot be trusted and
then there's this meme coming out of the
whole tattoo thing which I gotta say is
pretty funny look at this Photograph
it's sure for God damn sure
what the man
why would you send me this
thank you
um also we have the log here of stock
photo picture frame that was used in the
Pro uh oh it was a stock photo well of
course it was he sent it to me after
like 30 seconds but he didn't remove the
damn watermark
right there it is so he took it from one
two three RF
okay
wonderful
well done sir beautiful
It's a Wonderful frame
it's gorgeous yeah it's massive perfect
for a tattoo
I love frames I'm just super absolutely
absolutely you don't have to put the
image in there I just love frames and
this is a beautiful frame
so thank you for that it's just what I
wanted
uh today we have planned some people
were saying Ethan you need to try more
Korean food because clearly you're a
pleb and you don't because I was talking
about
um
Yaki
timbanyaki where they kick the meat you
cook the meat
that's Korean barbecue no that's nice
yeah that's Japanese right Teppanyaki
people were saying Korean barbecue is
way more than Korean barbecue the Korean
cuisine I says okay fine I didn't say
that I don't like you know I'm not I'm
not speaking for the whole country of
Korea I mean we love Korean food we love
all things Korea except the north part
right hate the north love everything in
the south
absolutely not the people of the north
we love them it's just that fat
little
but it's not because he's fat
yeah why'd I say that I don't know why I
went there with him because I think why
I went there is because everybody in
that country is starving yeah and he's
like fat as there's something more
to it you know what I mean yeah like
everyone's like oh God I'm I'm eating
Roots I'm digging Roots out of the
ground and trying to catch my neighbor's
dog so that my children will feed and
he's walking around like goddamn
veruca's uh yeah Violet after she turned
into a blueberry right
so that's what you're saying is
Batman bad
and this that in this case is bad yeah
right don't call them a fat pig you
can't do it yeah I didn't I didn't say
that that's mean
uh so I'm gonna try a whole bunch of
Korean food I guess right Sam
he's not here thanks Sam thank you to
Sam gets me every time
oh who's put it did Sam put it together
yes yes yes she just not in her seat
right now so how did we do this did we
order the food did she make the food
does anyone have no she's ordered from a
couple places I believe uh yeah
[Music]
now I'll say this I don't know if she's
respected this wish of mine but I don't
like seafood
pretty much across the board it's not a
lot of seafood in Korea there's like
that's not the main thing really on a
meat yeah there's a lot a lot of meat
they don't with seafood
yes they do but they do like anyone else
does yeah I guess that's fair to say
okay
no we're not bringing out the whole
ocean I'm so excited the Japanese they
love lots of seafood in Japanese food
yes
I should say this is
just
korean-american food because I don't
know how popular seafood is in actual
Japan is all about the respect but like
Korean food here in Los Angeles is
mostly meat not a lot of seafood thank
you
thank you so much I gotta say it's my
favorite dish or like uh Cuisine oh yeah
Korean you love green food actually you
know what I'm gonna say it's always nice
it's always a nice experience with the
family and everyone when you go out
um and get Korean food I agree Korea but
I've only done it once and it was hot
it was hot
it was very hot there was a Hot Grill in
front of us it was hot I see Korea is
very sensitive to temperature I've
noticed
well
I am delicate like it bugs you when it's
too hot or too cold and like I am
delicate my friend uh unless I'm like
Goldie I'm like gold box yeah of
podcasting Korea is a peninsula
surrounded by sea thank you baby
which has historically made Seafood a
readily available at import of Korean
diet Seafood is not only abundant but
also highly valued in Korean cuisine and
is a key ingredient many traditional
dishes AB just called you guys Liars
there you go uh chat GPT that's your boy
that's your boy
uh
so I hate to be the bearer
so um we also got new well I have my new
Shrek Crocs I want to show off with Sam
but she's not here she unfortunately
forgot hers today what then I'll wait
for her because I made her wait for me
they were here the other day
we're home I guess yeah she took them
home oh I'll wait
there guys take a look stick right nice
awesome looks great look at this Crocs
[Applause]
um
oh man
you guys
Lena saw James Charles after the last
time
yeah I don't know if y'all remember it
happened a little while ago but a b and
Lena were like we see James Charles
sister and we're like take a picture and
he had us all on the edge of our seats
in our uh group chat
and then after you know leading us on
for what seemed like ours
he took a did he end up taking a photo
and it didn't look anything like I took
a photo and it wasn't James Charles it
was it was it was John Gnarls John
narrow a very respectable man yeah yeah
shout out specific he dates older women
he's straight and he dates old women
oh uh here I am saying Shrek car
everyone like this okay so I'll just
play it for you yeah I don't want to
miss this
breaking news Shrek Crocs I have my pair
too
[Music]
Shrek correct thank you you
know he's got a fat one
though talk like you know he's got a
thick
damn tree trunk oh yeah Shrek
does you say that oh yeah he did
you think Shrek has a huge Cog of course
no no it's part of the why you disagree
you don't know it's part of the lore
yeah it's a known thing you think Shrek
Is Not packing a tree trunk
Brock in my mouth like I'm talking
I'm
mom
oh she can't hear me yet
am I in am I doing this right you sure
are
she can't hear me well let's we I'd like
to enjoy this like an appetizer
I love when the touch in the screen is
fantastic participants too you video
shop react
you guys get tickled when you see the
finger like touch the camera it's so
sick it's so funny isn't it yeah very
hello hi are you there
I I am babe I can't see you I can only
see me okay
what's a good that's dad's fault
oh there we go
bless you thank you how are you doing
you just came back from a funeral huh I
did
I um you already got your Dodgers cap on
though we're moving on quickly from that
no no no my my girlfriend's husband was
a Dodger fan so everyone at the funeral
had their dodger blue gear on oh that's
nice
yeah I took off my jersey because it was
so bloody hot but I had a jersey on too
did you take the Jersey off at the
funeral
no I wore the jersey the funeral here
I'll show you my jerseys
dad and I got it on Fan Appreciation Day
and uh it's Mueller which isn't that or
Beulah rather he's not on our team
anymore
so they so they've given you out old
jerseys on Fan Appreciation Day the
guy's not even on the channel every day
they have I mean whenever they have fan
appreciation day they give you different
things if you get there it's first come
first serve so if you get there early
like Dad and I always go to the game
like you know an hour early we we get
stuff like there was a bobble head night
which we didn't make actually but did
they hand you that Jersey after he was
already gone
oh no he was on the team at the time
right yeah good what do you do with all
the jerseys you know when they trade
someone away you got to do something
with all the old jerseys I wonder what
I still wear it I still wear it right
okay
Dodge you're always a Dodger you know
you didn't get called out at the funeral
for wearing an old player
no no no I didn't I didn't and so the
reason I wanted to talk to you today Mom
is that there's this issue we've been
dealing with of H3 H3 producatones are
you aware knew you were gonna do that I
I love that okay and do you know what I
want to talk to you about specifically
well I mean it was it was parody and she
doesn't I know this when I when Dad and
I were over the house the other day and
dad everyone seemed to know that you
were getting a tattoo but I told you Mom
I told you before you told me I I
totally did not remember you saying you
were gonna get a tattoo and then I saw
the you know your mother here's myopic
and so all I saw was you know Shredder
and and I thought it was really cute
although I must say I was a little
suspicious when I saw the top hat yeah
well some I had a tattoo artist pitch me
this and I was like the you sent me
in a top hat and it doesn't even look
like
kind of weird and but you said you loved
it
well you know I love the fact that
Shredder looked it looked a lot like
Shredder except for that that uh uh dog
had pointed ears where Shredder's ears
kind of flopped a little bit yeah
I don't know if you do get a tattoo of
Shredder
um where would you put it so I'm
actually going to get it this Saturday I
found a new artist and I'm gonna do it
um right here on my forearm
can you see that's gonna hurt
on the forearm I've heard that that's a
sensitive area it's not that bad
I don't think so from what I heard I
don't think it's a terrible spot just
where the elbow creases hurts which are
you doing lower than that oh that's
crazy no I'm not going to the crease I'm
not creasing it brother
what is it
it's going to be small how big is it
going to be
um I'm thinking of doing a full sleeve
no way like a full sleeve and in half my
face will be Shredder's face so it's
like just shows the melding of our
spirits
I have a photo um a little preview I'll
show you what what we've got because I
showed it actually here this is this is
perfect what do you think about this one
that's now that's my dog
[Applause]
but his ears are pointy
why can't you just do it from a picture
of of Shredder well that was that was
kind of the problem yeah
okay I mean look well Mom here so here's
the preview of the tattoo
okay
oh God Ethan
you're a weirdo
okay
here's the previous tattoo uh let me
pull it up
you already have the air
the aircon it's so
like but yeah they're like son can I
tell you what what does that means it
doesn't turn on the AC and they live in
the valley where it's 100 degrees every
day right not father like son Dan take
that back
she says it's hot here this is the
tattoo by the way Donna
Ethan actually has the air conditioner
on too high
and I'm usually pulling I keep telling
you guys
you have to get someone out there to
look at the pressure there's no air
pressure you guys are just running
you just got to call an AC guy but I
don't know you guys don't want to do it
I don't I don't know I mean your air
conditioner that was the air conditioner
you put in yeah it's great it's a really
good one yeah which is as big as me
yeah so I don't know
okay you all right here's the tattoo
um it's covered with the play button
just because I took a screenshot of the
video but this is what it's going to
look like
that's that's a pretty good sized one so
then when are you going to put Alfredo
on your other arm
I mean he's not not right now not right
now
just ready
yeah I think about that terrible day
yeah I'm not thinking about that come on
Mom ready ready shred it well yeah you
can make me think about alfredo
yeah shredders Shredder was your first
baby yeah he was very special he's my
boy yeah yeah but anyways that's
actually not the reason so the real
reason I'm talking to you is related to
burlesque Dons but it's not your
engagement with this sweep
now so what happened was you realized I
said Mom block this guy
right he keeps tricking you
okay well yeah okay and then
um I'm just uh like I said I'm myopic
and I should have known that it was a
parody and uh your fans were the ones
that were like do me a favor do me a
favor do me a favor open your uh open
your phone and go to my Twitter page
ah
then you're gonna you're gonna lose me
is that's okay well can we hear her
I think we'll still hear you if you
minimize okay go to your Twitter page go
to your Twitter page and go to my
actually I don't think
you just want to see us
yeah we can still see her okay yeah this
is perfect uh here we go
Oh see it's on the top how am I going to
do that because my I'm in the way you
can probably move it down yeah okay okay
oh I see I see your that stupid God
which I cannot get off of my phone
well go to my page
h3h3productions that's yeah I know
spelled correctly I'm yeah not
productons
okay here you are here's your H3 and
what do you see there
I see your logo and it says the official
oh there's your there's the picture of
your arm
wait that can't be right okay she's on
the wrong three podcasts this is off the
rails is going live okay this is one of
those
and it's a picture of a shredder in a
suit with a bow tie with roses right so
that you're looking at you're looking at
productons again
well I'm going to Twitter well yeah no
we'll send you the link it's at
h3h3productions right okay I didn't put
the ad we got the bot we got the Howie
Mandel Mischief music
h
oh here Dan's sending it to me okay
so hold on hold on no no yeah I just
opened it oh it's it's it's Howie Mandel
is in the corner and that guy that
parody right go down it says it's
blocked I blocked him you blocked him
him being who
the guy who pretends it's you blocked me
whose page are you on right now I just
sent you the link to Ethan's page
I know I just I just touched what you
and so right and so that page is blocked
wait a minute okay here's the link when
you're ready okay I'm touching it yeah
and then it comes up
this other guy and it's because I
blocked him
[Laughter]
is my page thank you Lena right and then
if you go to my page it says what
at h3h3 Productions is blocked are you
sure you want to view these posts I'm
confused all right I'll just because
it's a picture of you without any hair
well we've a lot of weight he has the
same uh profile picture as me
that's not your profile picture that you
had before I changed I changed it like I
don't know a few months ago to that
mm-hmm
it was just funny because there was like
um these Alpha Bros I guess were passing
they thought it was a real photo of me
so I decided to make it my
profile picture
well how the hell am I supposed to
well you look at that Mark are you the
one with the check mark
well that doesn't mean anything anymore
unfortunately thank you Elon no but just
look how my handle spelled that's how
you tell
well one of them says at the okay at the
H3 podcast is not you that's the podcast
that is the podcast
that is the part the podcast is separate
podcast it's not my personal Twitter but
that is our podcast Twitter account
okay well that's what I was
well what about mom here read this read
this uh can she see this pull up pull
back up your camera
and then read this
all right hold on
I'm on Zoom yeah if you come back to
zoom uh you might have to turn your
camera back on
click the little camera icon
it's old timing thank you Elon by the
way for verifying everybody that was a
that was a really that was a great movie
yeah fantastic absolutely okay I can see
you so do you see the screen I have a
but you see the tweets there I put for
you to read
no
okay I'll just okay I'll read it too
chat oh wait I want to see your face
though I want to see your face
uh can she see that yeah Donna can you
see if you can turn your camera back on
I thought I did ah
Zoom start video that's our video yep
okay wait let me see if I can do that
again oh God I hate this
you're okay yeah if you just hit that
start video it should come right back
oh now I'm watching something weird like
a car right you're seeing our video but
we we can't see you your camera there it
is okay there you are all right so Mom
what I wanna what I want to tell you
today
is that you did block an account
was it you you blocked me
and you left Productions
oh my God he got you again
look at the he got you man thank
you mom so do you wanna you know what
when I see you guys Sunday you're gonna
have to help me figure this thing out I
can help you right now
okay all right what do I do so go to H3
Street production you know what I'll
help you when I see him I'm not sure
this is gonna be the best content but
until then don't talk to Ethan over
Twitter
well you just have to click unblock I
mean this is a button right there click
boom yeah I'll unblock you I thought
that was his account I know
block me he got you again I'm telling
you this guy no this guy's a problem
really tricky I mean how can your fans
find you I don't know but this guy
production is a real Menace like I'm
thinking of taking legal action against
all I know is your fans kept us saying
Donna it's a parody and I thought oh
so he's answering all of the the uh
comments like I know I know I'm trying
to figure it out here's a thread you
said I know I know I just blocked him
and then the response you blocked the
wrong account Donna you blocked your son
Donna you blocked your son Donna
everyone's yelling at you
because they they no they can see who
you're following
really okay yeah yeah all right well I
should do this right now I'm gonna
unblock you
maybe look at that how about this we'll
call you back in 10 minutes and see
okay so all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
unblock you call me back all right all
right we'll check in on you let's see if
I can turn this thing off
all right
leave it
all right here's Twitter
what the hell
oh
I can't even turn you guys off
let's see why is this happening here
Ethan I don't think I can do this wait
let me get rid of this thing okay here
we go
that's my favorite part all right
unblock unblock all right well thank you
mom we'll we'll talk to you in a minute
skip trying we'll call you back in 10
okay I got it I already got it is there
a picture of Howie Mandel up in the
corner this looks the same as mine he
made his look identical to mine it's
identical in every way except the handle
I don't know if this is then
well I just unblocked it so if that's
that's not you
it sounds like maybe you did unblock me
so now you gotta go figure out how to
block protocols
that villain
yeah you're talking about uh all right
talking about wrestle we'll send you the
link we'll send you the link to
Productions okay you know who's dude
yeah oh here's his I don't like this
picture of you you're so why are you
making yourself look like that
I think it's just it's just a it's just
a silly little joke about because
yeah I've never known a person try to
make themselves look goofy like you all
right wait let me see
all right that's Donna Klein everybody
my mom
just got back from the funeral
she's the best Walker outside
[Applause]
you're everything after everything mom
what's that babe
after everything we've been through
I know
we have been through a lot we've been
through a lot she's back you're back I'm
back
so now I have to push leave right
oh just for the record Ethan do you and
your fans this you know what this Friday
is huh
dad and I are going to be married 49
years wow congrats
a lot that's a big one
's gonna be 49 years what do you guys
gonna do for 50.
don't ask
he goes
do you still love me
I mean is it a trick question
oh brother
he says of course yeah of course he does
what do you guys doing 50. that's the
big one right
yeah I don't know what we're doing dad's
knees are uh an issue so we'll have to
figure out where we're gonna go
I can get him a mobility scooter Hey
listen if we go to Europe you cannot be
handicapped it's not a handicap friendly
place to be really they didn't do the
ADL or whatever well you know
you're so old and everything's
Cobblestone and and all of them you
should you should see there's really
beautiful mobility scooters you can get
with like really good traction and huge
Wheels
yeah and how are you supposed to get
upstairs when you want to go to the
Metro is it no the two there's a ramp at
the Metro yeah not in Europe
just all of Europe no ramps on any
metros
I there's there wasn't one that I saw
can I get a picture of a ramp at a Metro
I mean I'll fact check this
okay check check
um Dad and I were okay Spain England
France
and Italy what do you think that the
people in wheelchairs do
they're screwed they're screwed one of
my close friends is in um she has a
walker and she was going to be taking a
European Vacation and she
she changed it she changed it because
there's just no way for her to be able
to get around we haven't been able to
find a single ramp in Europe yet and the
guys are looking I haven't found it I'm
telling you it's an it's just like a
very specific I mean I found an article
about wheelchair accessibility in the
London Tube so it sounds like oh so here
this could be dad I mean well they bust
out the special the red carpet you might
say this one's Denmark the next one is
Brussels so we'll have to so this one's
Denmark Brussels
look at the respect that that you get
here you know
that's good so ask that I'll get i'll
for your guys 50s I could buy him a
Mobility Scooter of his dreams
Mobility Scooter to Europe if we even go
to Europe ask him if he prefers ask him
if he first the one with the straw or
the one where he controls by hand
the straw
those are for like paraplegics but I
understand he's pretty lazy
that's what it is right yeah you blowing
it that's correct
all right I love you guys I'm gonna go
have lunch and and spend some time with
your father who still loves me
all right Mom have a great day thanks
for calling thanks guys okay sweetheart
I'll see you Sunday all right thanks for
unblocking me
thanks
leave there we go
and there she goes she vanishes into
a ethereal Mist well there we go we got
I think we got food tour yeah but you
know we did it I feel bad for the Joe
for people like you brick people my
mom's age is not as technologically uh
you know literate as as us for them for
not all but some and Elon Musk really
their lives up with this
this check mark yeah my poor mom she
doesn't know any she's she's totally
lost on Twitter you're still looking for
check marks
all right
anyway thank you Mom
thank you
meanwhile I'm trying to get Jimmy Lee on
tigerbelly looks like we're gonna make
it happen
okay I'm super happy to say I I called
in a favor with Bobby Lee
I said Bobby I need a favor he said I
tried to call you what's up King he
thought it was an emergency tried to hit
me up wow
you're burning a lot of favors on Jimmy
gotta say
burning all different I'll get him back
I'll get him back okay
I said okay I have a friend comedian
Jimmy Lee it's kind of hard to explain
but he's this wild character he's been
on the show a bunch and he just did
Howie's podcast I think you guys would
have been saying chemistry
I just wanted to suggest him for your
show I love him and I want to see him
spread his wings but the Howie app
actually got really good views for him
so I think the episode do really well
our fans will love it he says okay
George will handle it
let's go wow so Jimmy is gonna be on
what we said around around September or
December I mean
that was the next time that he was going
to be in town so yeah he's not going to
come in for Bobby Lee
this is even bigger opportunity than how
well maybe he will I don't know I don't
know yet yeah
are you in contact with George the
schedule yeah I messaged him did he
respond I haven't heard back yet oh
I might have to stay on them
so there it is also Jimmy made an
appearance on the Tom Ward show this is
the collaboration of a
of a lifetime hold it look at this
Tom and Jimmy together at last
bald and balder
[Music]
we love him though
uh we love them for that
I started the music officially in 04.
and I stopped in like 12 and I started
comedy at 13. so I've been in comedy 10
years
wow okay 10 years how old are you now
nice one but you didn't even smile he's
like no I'm 23. I'm 23. yeah that's the
real that's that's true when you started
this year 50s but you can't tell Ethan
oh
that's a direct question what is your
age he won't tell you
why don't you answer that um
I can't get him out of it Tom
I can't get him out of it Tommy we had
to do some deep
um investigation where people really
went crazy like found his yearbook
photos which is actually really
interesting I don't know if one of you
guys can pull that up he looks he's he's
a strapping young lad
but the guys he's 66 I'm pretty sure
that's the age we've unveiled it sorry
Tom we got the exclusive on that one
me Denise and that's why I'm laughing
what no he did not what did what did you
say oh Ethan wait what do you mean
that's a direct question what is your
age
I don't know
oh yeah right he got more
you got more here's Jimmy in high school
he graduated on like 1940 or something
he says uh 1975
okay overshot a little bit
so
um fantastic
huge collaboration guys I suggest
everybody go support both of them here's
the thumbnail I got a couple of great
moments here
of these two greats what the that's
the thumbnail
it's a goblin mode
dude I think I still mentioned Goblin
mode I think that might he might be
taking it too far
he did the gobble mode in the thumbnail
I like it like Yoda
well he yeah probably assumed we were
going to talk about it so who drew that
actually no you know what you want I
mean that kind of looks like our
thumbnails
yeah and our titles so I can't hate on
that yeah Taylor Swift
Jamie Lee the outlaw
uh I mean I guess honestly try it
we love that
switching it up he's switching it up man
although he discouraged that it looks
like he's one of his own stories
you're in all of your own thumbs too I
know but like you got to do it like
dobrik where your head face is huge and
you're reacting otherwise he just looks
like he's another character in the story
yeah
who's the main character in his own
story
you know aren't we all
um let's see
full videos out Tom asked Jimmy about a
sample of his jokes oh brother I hope
you're ready for this one Tommy Boy but
you know it's like almost Clark Kent and
Superman two two different characters
well let's hear more let's hear some
jokes man we heard from Dr Weiner for
11 minutes if people are still
watching right so if people who don't
know did they need did they leave
already I I find this interesting I hope
hopefully other people do so an example
of the jokes for people who aren't
familiar with your comedy the street
stuff so I do stereotypic you know
insult style humor so if you're a black
MMA how long you've been black what
all right how's Town gonna take that so
if you're a black guy for example
and if you're a dark hey okay Tom liked
it a little black guy I'm gonna say I've
seen a lot of black people but so you're
overdoing it you know something like
Whoa have we heard that one
oh that's crazy sir you're overdoing
your that's crazy Jimmy
Tom how are you gonna take that one if
you're Chinese now I think he's worried
his the face the smile faded a bit and
then it turned into uh finish the
sentence so an example of the jokes for
people who aren't familiar with your
comedy the street stuff so I do
stereotypic you know insult style humor
so if you're a black MMA you've been
black and if you're a dark-skinned black
guy I'm gonna say I've seen a lot of
black people but so you're overdoing it
you know something like that if you're
Chinese I'm gonna say no starch on the
collar please we talked about this
before uh uh and by the way do you have
any Duck Sauce so it's very stereotypic
humor if you're a super racist you have
large breasts I'm going to say it's
quite a set of Tenacious you got there
oh my God let me saying so
uh when you ask permission to insult
someone it's funny so I walk up to a
girl and I say may I say something and a
girl goes showing you and you go okay
you got to be one of the ugliest Bros
and you walk away so when you ask
permission it makes it funny so I can
Vibe
look at the people first of all I can
feel whether I'm going to be able to hit
him and they're going to like it if they
don't no I won't go but then I have to
figure out to say the best one I did
um are you able to go on the Instagram
something really funny because it's
hysterical
this is probably
oh my God sir I think you're doing it
too much don't you think
yeah the Instagram is everything for for
jimin he has a million so 1.1 actually
oh it's gone up yeah oh my God he's at
1.1 I'm dead serious he's gonna
he's gonna pass me by the time
comes along you're getting a hundred
thousand followers
well yeah because he had a big
appearance on this show
how he did it too you know Howie I mean
yeah tremendous numbers on Howie
Mandel's show maybe he took another
flight to Brazil
uh
right they love him there
or Brazil they say yeah so that was a
pretty fun moment I mean that that was
some new artillery from Jimmy
definitely keeping it fresh definitely
don't do that joke Jimmy if you're
watching
don't do that one
um
Jimmy talks about how he can't do racist
jokes anymore with the quote blocks
oh brother
uh you know I just my wife always says
you're going to get famous or get killed
that's actually tells me so what do you
do like when you do race stuff I mean do
you get dude shout out Jimmy drinking
from this red Solo cup is he kegging it
or what yes for sure
sexist or the problem the problem with
the black jokes is you can't do the real
rough ones anymore so I stopped them
not like the one where you tell a black
person they're going a little too far
oh my God
sometimes I forget how racist his
is and then I'm like oh
amid flash I can do age I can do weight
I can do education I can't do the race
once too much
um I had some real good ones but they're
too rough
um this is kind of what I was talking
about the other day when you're asking
about the crossover with Bobby Lee but I
didn't expect it to happen on the Tom
Ward podcast it's almost it's in a way
it's almost like the less pushback the
more emboldened he becomes because Tom
is like an empty you know canvas for for
Jimmy's expression right and so he
doesn't see someone being like Yo dude
maybe don't say that joke
I feel like Bobby's gonna encourage him
it's going to be and that's what I was
right exactly dude it's going to be so
freaking entertaining it's gonna be
great yeah but it's gonna be like
Titanic it's going to sink it's like
done it was beautiful while I was going
on but the thing is Jimmy can't be
canceled like he has nothing it's only
up he has only to gain from this right
we hold the keys here just like his
follower account although he's uh my
concern is that he'll say something so
heinous that we'll have to like
that's what I meant that's what I was
trying to say he's pretty close I I said
if he goes on if he goes on the podcast
with Bobby Lee there's a good chance
that that's the end of the Jimmy Lee
Saga on the history
like I could see that happening kind of
because sometimes bobby gets carried
away too Jessie Crespo just donated five
dollars said I'll say it again Bobby's
gonna get Jimmy to drop down bomb no way
I mean listen I think
we may lose Jimmy because of this but uh
sacrifice him well yeah I really don't
think so I don't think so it's like the
final test final current call
it's true in a sense if he can pass the
Bobby Lee test then maybe he's here for
the long run
I mean he's old not that long but in the
in the showtime of figure of speech
not in like the long life longevity type
of speech
although he is 70 his sales which is he
has had a good run ready 66. no 66.
um Jimmy says he'll be at our live show
our next live show that's news to me
news to us yeah I wasn't sure about that
I mean we haven't really planned it out
I have not that he's not invited we just
haven't really sent out invitations yet
here's what we said we said we're gonna
keep you posted because when he was here
he kept asking about it I mean he's more
than welcome to come as a guest I don't
know if I'm ready to do another like
tomatoes thing
oh yeah I mean that's I'd love to see
him like on a personal level let's let's
wait for the tiger belly episode we'll
let him know exactly
that's true
Brad Stein who's helping us on
distribution so we have people on the
back end and then the other upcoming
thing is the H3 H3 live show in December
we're going to be out there that always
is a big Vibe so that's the upcoming
thing it's always a Vibe he says it like
it's a Comedy Festival like we're gonna
be out in La for the H3 podcast show
Good Vibes out there we'd like to get
out there and give them some a good time
it's like he's doing us a favor now we
should do once a year and and it really
works because now a year we've done it
once Jimmy
but anyway the views are quite good I
have to say Jimmy is kind of pulling the
viewership
like if you look at Howie the show did
the episode of great Tom Ward he's
crushing it so far four hours three
point five thousand views I think that's
pretty good for Tommy Boy
I mean if you look at his last episode
from 12 days ago he our boy didn't even
get 600 views which is
pretty incredible
it's impressive
I
don't know man I feel like I used to
share
my videos on Facebook and get more views
than that but
he's working it he is working
isn't he Jimmy basically told him don't
give up keep going he said I commend
people like you that's good advice yeah
I mean that's sweet I mean look at Jimbo
all right so that's that check it out
guys if y'all are interested how we
actually had Carrot Top on and another
weird twist of fate
um
we tried to get carried on
via Jimmy actually
and Trisha had carrot on how weird is
that and then how we had carrot on and
then how we talked to carrot about me
hmm
um and so I guess me and Cara are just
star-crossed lovers
um but we'll hopefully our past cross
how was how was um carrot job I typed
character you ever get a carrot job
Carrot Top I guess top can mean like
a carrot job you get a carrot up your
ass
wait I was curious
to tell you
this woman walking he says I have man
he's such an interesting dude caratop
reveals the most chaotic moments from
his career
That was supposed to be my exclusive
um oh man here we go so here's how we
talking to uh carrot about me
where is it here it is
uh it's muted of course attack but it's
an apology and it's an apology to Ethan
Klein and the H3 podcast
um I'm a fan Ethan you know I love you I
love you too I see you out there this
clip
dude listen to this Jimmy
okay first of all this and says do you
want carrot
this like framing they've done is
incredible yeah dude his editors are
really stepping their game up the whole
vibe there is fantastic oh yeah he
should probably he should preview all
videos they watch through the lens of
the prolapse or maybe end the episodes
with That's all folks through the
prolapse right That's all folks
um bit top on your show
and he sends me a picture of him with
Carrot Top
and I'm thinking there's no damn way he
can get a Carrot Top not that I think
that Carrot Top is like a super hard Gap
I mean peace and love I like Carrot Top
I like him I like carrot I always laugh
when I see his pits man
I'm like Jimmy doesn't he can't get me
in buddy right so I said yes Jimmy I
want Carrot Top just to see if he could
do it he sent us a number
so you should know that I have a history
did we I don't know if we said this
buddy
he's unavailable on the weekend
otherwise right the only day they could
do is on the weekend and you know we
don't
don't around on the weekends
no it's not even a carrot thing I just
don't Obama doesn't get me in on
the weekend you know what I mean
um hey Dan I need to correct the record
Bueller the Dodger pitcher is just
injured and out of the Season he'll
return in 2024. oh thank God so he's
still a Dodger oh my mom okay that's for
my mom
okay good please correct on the air my
mom said I feel terrible
we love you Walker Buehler
Euler
she said uh once a Dodger always a
Dodger does that apply to the one that
um
which one the one that just got fired
for uh beating up his girlfriend or wife
or something Julio Urias
what's his name Zach Julio Urias it's so
I should ask her is Right still a Dodger
yeah
good question I mean these are hard
questions we need to be asking Dodger
fans they pulled his bobblehead night
oh okay it sounds like they're taking
serious action no he's done like yeah
he's he's gone
so um anyway here's Howie
carrotop
I actually called him he is doing he's
on this episode I did not take the idea
from you number one and number two I
apologize when I saw this I was so
pissed I was like how we got the
idea from us right you know what
happened Jimmy gave Howie the contact
and and then Carrick booked Howie before
he could come on our show
it's totally messed up and the
allegiances are all over the place oh
Jimmy Jimmy does not know where his
bread is buttered that's right he
doesn't
for not going through through Jimmy we
just got him ourselves I'm actually
surprised you didn't go through Jimmy
but next time for our next guest please
so we apologize to uh Jimmy Lee the
Jersey Outlaw and uh mostly to Ethan I'm
sorry thank you thank you guys subscribe
like
here's the podcast I love Howie you
really I mean of that stuff we didn't
this guy gets it man he is a he is a
National Treasure he really is
I genuinely my only hope in life is to
be as like
together with it
relevant funny as how he is not right he
like understands comedy you know I mean
today kids on the street
[Music]
um
and he's 70 how old is he he's like 76
he was in his 70s I think yeah that's
insane Howie
he is it's all that it's because he
doesn't with germs maybe that he
doesn't age 67.
a67 same age as Jimmy
so that's uh shout out to how we love
you Howie more coming up from Kenny
Smiles after this we got to go straight
to the Korean food because I don't want
that to ruin my life and get me
sick just being refrigerated I don't
think it'll be here for until oh it's
not here
no oh okay it's uh it will be here very
soon okay perfect I thought it was
sitting out so that's actually great
yeah also we we skipped over it but I
got to show the James Charles photos to
uh right thank you thank you so where
was this uh that you was this just Lena
are the both of you it was just me it
was at a beauty event
you're here at a beauty event must have
been pretty high level for James to be
there no yeah I went with Nicole
concilio um she invited me to go with is
that her
yeah she's a she's a makeup
so she was helping you out by pretending
to take a photo no she didn't know what
was going on I was just like oh my
goodness
she's not involved see even this photo
can ruin her career
even just having James over your
shoulder is a liability
oh my God but yeah this is him that is
the sister himself
so you guys to
we dig up the old photo of the Rando
that AB took a shot of oh that wasn't
can we find that I could find it yeah
that was so long ago that was years ago
now so what was the energy like there
around James Lena did you feel some kind
of aura oh I didn't get too close right
yeah smell anything any like kind of
sulfurous sort of like I didn't fart
yeah no no yeah like a demon smell
wow
well James there you are and uh people
are still hanging out with you so that's
always a surprise and a shock to me but
thank you Lena we see him he's out there
it's the real deal oh it's the real deal
I'm really sad
oh
uh I love Kenny smiles
hold on no you don't oh here Lena send
this back to um Nicole to Nicole okay we
fixed this for her
because I don't want
him
oh there you go no she's a friend of the
show and I don't want anything bad to
happen to her yeah yeah in fact can you
just take it one step further Cameron I
don't know who these people are but they
don't remember everyone remove everyone
but James please because they might just
be trapped in conversation we don't know
you know that I I don't want to put that
on there yeah yeah I found the James
Charles picture the original one
so here's the one that AV sent us oh man
that was all we had bro that's just so
tiny that's just something dude man
oh my God I'm telling you he was looking
back at me and I'm like oh I'm just like
getting paranoid I'm like he saw the
content Court he saw the content core
embarrassing Evie's got this whole thing
built up in his head he's just he was
really just stalking some poor kid oh
wait there's the secondary yeah I found
it
rectangle head
he that one's James coded yeah yeah he
does have that he's rectangular
yeah so let me know when that's ready
Karen and we'll send that out
you know what we should go we should go
here's a really good um service
let's follow James not like physically
but like when he goes to events we find
out and then we offer to um attendance
of the event that if he's in any of the
photos we can either remove him or
remove them
um
well to be Char there'd be a charge of
moves oh
you know how much how much would you
expect people to pay well it's a pretty
scary thing we could also do uh do an
element of blackmail too where it's like
well well we could remove it or we could
show it to everybody I see
it's a good kind of blackmail too
because you don't have to
you don't have to be explicit about it
you know it's just implied all right
here's the this is the uh
and this is kind of
what I'd like to see uh in the close
proximity of James that people just flee
from the scene maybe Chris Hansen in
there you know what's actually kind of
upsetting and unfair is like this event
like if people recognize where he is
they're gonna think like they wanted him
there whereas he might have just crashed
it right bro this looks like cookies for
you I don't know where this is but it
looks like
like a Middle School cafeteria you know
when they set it up
I was gonna say like oh no it does why
did they do it what is this place Lena
it's like one of those warehouses but I
think um it was actually nice inside
they had like a lot of activities like
they did tarot reading I thought that
was super cool
um but also at the companies based in
New York so I think maybe they just
didn't Scout the areas or the locations
in La before choosing one
but it was it was fine it was nice did
you get your fortune red I did what did
it what did they tell you
um just good things ahead I don't know
if they said I mean it's like I think
Lena's afraid
things ahead I need to know girl I mean
I don't know if I believe it anyway it's
because it's like an event full of like
content creators and stuff maybe they're
just telling people like what Lena just
say it Ethan's not gonna carry it it has
to do with her job oh
tarot card what does she know that I
don't no nothing okay well if you insist
baby she said um that uh the cards say
that I'm good at my job and I get paid
well and I like it and stuff but the
universe is telling me to be open to
other opportunities that will be coming
girl hey yo the cards dude that's what
the universe is that's like a guarantee
something big is coming the magic was in
that warehouse
you know I don't usually believe in that
stuff but Lena went to get her palm read
like years ago like in 2016 2017 yeah
and the lady got it really like spot on
like she
she said there's someone in your guys's
lives you're in your relationship and
she gave the initial and she's like
that's that's putting you guys through
hell and at the time I did have acts
that was driving us you want to say
their first and last name I wish her
nothing but device
this is the exact location I don't care
what anyone says look at this photo that
is where James Charles is in that
photograph
that is a freaking Middle School Dance
okay let's not let him in there I mean
Lena listen I don't want you to leave
but I mean surely if something gray came
along I'd be I'd be uh nothing but
thrilled for you oh thank you I mean no
I told her I'm content with my work and
stuff and she said well just be open
just be open yeah
just be open and I I encourage everyone
to just be open you know what I mean
just be open
I liked that she said you're paid well
though
yeah she goes she goes don't ask for any
raises you're fine
I wish we could have uh found out what
James's Fortune was that would have been
pretty cool that would have been good
you could have slidered five bucks under
the table hey what was the reading for
that guy with the weird hair okay now
hold the phone what is this was
this the night before
because that's James right it's my bar
mitzvah dude that's James at the same
damn
the same damn place dancing with like
Teenage like really young boys this is
making me uncomfortable
I gotta get out of this oh
that's gross
Hello Olivia well that was fun
and for anybody at home who wants to uh
have their own James Charles Odyssey I
was thinking
we don't want to offend anyone not the
not the place it was at no people he's
just
there by himself let's tweak that out
this one yeah so people can you know
create their own Adventures well I made
this one I left cam do a clean version
yeah yeah
thank you
yeah peace and love to everybody in the
world except you James
not you
I love everybody in the world I mean
they're all gosh not you we're all God's
children
every person in this world deserves a
second chance
we are all deserving of God's love not
you
and
I just truly truly believe that
we are only we are who we are we're made
in God's image and therefore we're
blameless in a sense in our crimes you
need to leave
James you need to get the out of
here and I just truly believe that if we
can come together and understand
that we are all just the product of our
environment to remove blame to remove
you know pain to remove the
the righteous punishment that we might
feel we have to James get out
[Music]
get the out freak if we could just
remove that aspect that's something that
I can't turn off hi sisters what is this
Cameron
what why does this exist I didn't do
that one I just found it online I what I
love what who made that I don't know I
just looked at James Charles angel I'm
gonna get that tattooed on my inner
forearm maybe why did you make this
hello James so is he dead
he's transcended he's in space he's in
Sister Heaven
tugging on his hoodie strings oh no oh
no all right another thing so he's not
dead
all right you know hello let me watch
the Sun
excuse me this Dr Kenny thing and then
it sounds like the food is here
so let's see what's up with our boy
Kenny so you want some tea we
want some teeth
let's see
man this life's this guy's life has got
to be being ruined right now right like
there's no shot
this is just out there living his normal
life right now don't know how but it
keeps getting worse another verified
patient of Dr Kenny has reached out to
me to share her excruciating encounters
with Dr Kenny that resulted in her
needing surgery by a cardiothoracic
surgeon to remove Dental fragments from
her lungs I'm keeping This Woman's
identity concealed similar to our
victims that we've talked about so far
this young woman flew out to Texas to
have her teeth done by Dr Kenny in
August of 22. unfortunately but not
shockingly her first appointment was
nothing less than traumatizing during
her appointment Dr Kenny's staff
overseen by Dr Kenny did mold
impressions of her teeth and they left
the mold in her mouth for 10 minutes
until it was hardened when staff went to
remove the hardened mold from her mouth
it broke apart inside of her mouth and
this young woman breathed in a fragment
of this broken mold yo that's crazy she
breathed in the plaster
based on those complaints we're reading
I'm not surprised it's all like not
taking proper care and not doing the
proper procedure stuff along those lines
in the earlier complaints that sounds
like a life-changing injury potentially
I don't know what this text is but he's
saying damn you're hot as
by the way apparently he's a Mormon
apparently that's what I read I you
could fact check it but I think he's a
Mormon
which um is super it doesn't make sense
because Mormons are you know they don't
do it
don't do stuff like this
and he's not really Glazed if I may say
so he's more like this Reddit post
that he did Mormon missionary work in
Guatemala
oh
so he's doing missionary work here
by the way guys we'll tweet this out for
everybody at home who wants to
participate
in uh clearing the names of everyone at
that event
so
go to our podcast Twitter account thank
you so much
here he is
wait you said
you said something about him being a
missionary where is that I thought you
sent that oh no it's just a small Reddit
post I'm still looking all right anyway
causing her to aspirate Dr Kenny and his
staff were all aware that this woman was
choking and had reason to believe that
there was a broken off piece of the
mouth impression stuck in her lungs but
Dr Kenny and his staff chose to do
nothing no x-rays didn't send her to the
ER despite the fact that she had just
aspirated and was in discomfort what is
that what does aspirating mean
it's like uh trouble breathing I believe
but let me double check dude that's
crazy she just can't breathe he's like
all right well see you in three months
happens when food liquid or other
material enters a person's Airway and
eventually their lungs by accident okay
it's proceeded with her teeth now this
is where we're going to get into some
text mess
Dr Kenny so this is the girl he almost
killed and then he's like damn your God
as yeah we gotta uh we should stop
watching this video this was not checked
for claim and I think this music that's
in the background did you get a notice
are you just being cautious just being
cautious okay
so yeah basically the context is that uh
this patient was having those problems
and then he took a picture with her and
he said send to me so he could get her
number she sends the this is alleged by
the way just based off this thing of
course yes of course of course but uh
yeah he gets the image and then says
damn you're hot as and then she was
supposed to have a follow-up appointment
the next day he's like can we push it
back to 8 30 rather than eight he's like
unless you want to send a nude then I
could maybe no way yeah he's like then
maybe way how is this guy doing
this like it's weird there's a part two
where uh allegedly he's sending like
explicit uh photos dude her dentist send
her a text saying you're hot as
imagine that yeah that's nuts and I've
after he like basically did a
malpractice on her lungs
if I get a nude I can wake up a lot
faster
what
I'm speechless
oh Jimmy's upset Zach why I think he was
like under the in some assumption that
he was definitively coming out for the
live show I mean he's welcome to come I
just don't know what's the format of the
show we haven't really started to plan
it yet he so obviously one of his um one
of the people on his career text him
said the date which is public
um and he's like okay so not sure on me
okay let me know I don't want to come if
I'm not on I'm coming just for you
so just let me now oh I have to plan I'm
not upset I know he wants to plan I
think he's upset you think he's upset
yeah he got that info really fast yeah
so here's part two I don't know if this
one has the same music
I just checked that one as well it
appears to be okay okay thank you while
this young woman was waiting for her
permanent teeth to be done she obviously
flew back home and throughout
sending her unsolicited videos of his
manhood no and just weird videos in
general and I'm going to show you some
of the weird videos no well hold on why
isn't he in jail like he seems to be
doing this to so many people it's
actually I mean it's so sad that I mean
think about it that this guy so brazen
so disgusting
he's gotten away with this for so long
this is how hard it is to catch these
people because like
there's no reason this dude should not
be in jail
right now
dude thank God for tick-tocking
like this no way this would be picked up
by like mainstream that's true huh
yeah like people like this will not be
able to do like this or I mean I'm
sure they will but it's going to be
they're gonna be called way easier
that's a really good point yeah because
like I feel like the only way to uncover
this would be like some
local reporting where a bunch of people
like and that's that's tough and then
you have to plan on it getting like you
know National coverage
this is good you're right tick tock
forever dude
that goddamn is man
obviously
no
we're having a good day
I cannot I can't do this this is
potentially the most slime ball dude
that ever lived okay girl that's a good
question
I'm enjoying my day my hey girl you like
my Porsche
just got done got my haircut
he's a wife and kids by the way
the lip bite dude he's hot right now
though why are you worried about my wife
you think he went a little bit I love
you what's up girl why is he saying that
to his client I'm confused this is just
a client doctor relationship he spent
more time with her under anesthesia
probably
my design probably I don't believe he's
well that actually makes sense I don't
believe he's licensed to administer that
that was in one of the complaints if I'm
not mistaken for real but don't you need
an as special an Enthusiast to
administer that I don't even think
doctors can do it they need like the the
anesthesia yeah not actual anesthesia
but there was something mentioned uh
here let me find out what it was dude
that guy's got white
white Chompers man
got my hair cut
by the way I'm ready to do the food
basically whenever it's being prepared
right now well
I miss you
what
ew what is this man
[Music]
and obviously
he just gave her a hi girl hi that was
so gross what's this switch switch off
for a sec please Ian it's it's covered
but uh yeah this is supposedly
an image of his uh private that were
sent
oh so you're not showing this right
car it's it's more it's blurred it's
totally covered yeah no besides her she
blurted behind her as well but I just
caught I'll see what's going on here and
um
his dog is right there and his watch
and his ring wait Dr Kenny also began
asking this young woman to send
provocative photos of herself undressed
photos of herself and every time so did
he get her number from her like medical
records and no hey texting her he got it
from initially asking her to send him
that picture of them
God
how can you be this nuts
so I found that line in the complaint
that I was referring to uh I don't know
what's normal for Dennis but it says
respond it does not hold any sedation
slash anesthesia anesthesia permits
issued by the board
I got some Korean food coming breakfast
for me
okay
nice
so let's let's just let's Tell Kenny Dr
Kenny to go himself
we got food
suck it Dr Kenny
we can come back to that if anyone
actually wants to
understand so how should I approach this
do we have a method here
there's a method to the madness I
believe it's a list in the dock if you
want to scroll all of that or I can just
read them off to you but she's going to
be bringing them out in that order so uh
so this is essentially I am an
uncultured swine a western capitalist
egg right right I was saying how I
enjoyed Teppanyaki
but then I said I
I said I didn't like what do you call
that cabbage it's here kimchi kimchi
that offended a lot of people as I knew
it would
and people said oh you didn't like
kimchi then you have to try every Korean
food
here's the thread
as I when I was accused of Veena
a sick Western freak Ethan used to try
more Korean food I was dying listening
to the conversation about bull bulgogi
love was saying it so well like his
pronunciation was actually good say it
love bulgogi bulgogi
you know what's so good about the way
you say it
[Applause]
bulgogi a Korean food is so much more
than Korean barbecue and there's so many
dishes Sans fish flavor okay so that's
good they were thinking of me because I
don't like the fish so many good fried
and meat-based dishes which pair very
well with kimchi specifically so much to
enjoy and want to be enlightened okay so
this one just goes out to you okay rip
okay rip 8519 so Sam should I start or
wait
says you can go right ahead getting
I don't think there's anything in here
that I can eat to be honest really
because this looks like a potato
um the potatoes
okay so this is galbi Korean
style short ribbon I mean clearly who's
not gonna like this
right look at that I gave you the little
side dishes but don't try the kimchi yet
because that's one of the dishes
thank you
gotta have them ribs I mean it's
delicious it's like Teriyaki it's sweet
it's tender it's fatty and thick too
it's all happening
hahaha I don't think I need salt though
pretty well seasoned
mm-hmm
[Music]
shout out to uh galbi
which I am a fan of
now what are these sides what is this
[Applause]
I like radish
pickled rash wow that's very good
and do it oh I with that big
time Big Time
yeah you like pickled stuff which is why
I was surprised spicy it's got a good
flavor of good texture that's really
good it's delicious wait how do you call
this
I've never had this before
how do you call it okay is it the same I
don't know what perhaps
and perhaps what's this and perhaps what
is this I actually want to know I don't
know uh the Pickled radish I don't know
what it's called
the radish
that was so good oh my God
[Music]
there you go I just see a lot of things
referring to it as Korean pickled radish
so I'll say about the um I'm sure there
is a
while this is delicious I don't think
it's like super unique I mean I've had a
dish like this many times but the radish
I've never had
a dish like that so
I'm loving it
so far so good okay definitely
oh
Stan BTS standing BTS right now
[Music]
no one stand them harder
I'm smoking that BTS pack
[Music]
oh you want some close-ups of these okay
sure
sure I can do that I need some close-ups
this might be one of the best vegetable
dishes I've had man I truly love this
radish dish
so here take a look guys
there it is and perhaps what is this
delicious pickled radish apparently the
radish is called
panchan
it's just pickle radish
now this looks I don't think I'm gonna
like this because it's like
what's up
not crazy about the Hulk it just looks
like a giant sperm like look at it
[Music]
tell me that doesn't look like a sperm
that's literally a sperm you know it is
Dan
but it's like a Brussels sprout or
something I don't know
bean sprout so here I'm gonna try it
though
here's the money shot
nasty don't do it and that was nasty to
me it sound like that's him it's okay
I'm not crazy about the texture the
flavor's good but
this isn't something I'd probably order
just because of the all different
flavors these are usually side dishes
now perhaps what is this
does anyone know
potato
[Music]
okay it's like a sweet potato
stats it's good
you know the wheat oh my God I got soups
holy dude I'm like live translating
the shot BonChon is apparently just side
dish
oh okay that's side dish right I mean
like listen
great this is these potatoes are kind of
good actually they take you by surprise
a little bit
a little sweet
it's a journey I'm kind of laughing I
keep going back for another bite
[Music]
no
beat like BTS not as Dynamite as BTS I
like it okay so um I next I'm gonna try
the kimchi which
again I don't think I've ever tried
kimchi like more than a one or two two
times but this is
I would say people everybody loves
kimchi it seems right that's just stable
cheers
cheers my dude
it's a lot better than the one I had
previously really
it is a lot better yeah I like it
actually it's good
a little spicy if you just got a bad
batch it must be yeah I like this kimchi
this is good I like it I like it
I'm very into that I love all the
Pickled chip
okay I like it
what's going on here though these these
species I'm a little scared of like with
all the green and
wrinkles and I don't know what these
little pieces are is that just cabbage
okay
very good
kimchi jigay
[Applause]
[Music]
is that the soup
so wait what is kimchi what does kimchi
mean
is it now it's just a soup with kimchi
in it
yeah
catch a look at this
this is everybody's favorite
kimchi jigsaw
[Music]
a little piece of chicken little piece
of tofu
is your favorite Sam
[Music]
nice
let me try some of the chem chair
I like this segment this is the best
segment we've ever done everybody's just
silently watching me you guys didn't get
to participate
[Music]
oh Dan said there's a bunch in the
kitchen
do you guys can go away so kimchi refers
to fermented vegetables and and compast
salt Seasons so it's fermented
vegetables
does that mean there's alcohol in it
usually cabbage
cam can't
excuse me what happened
sorry he just started screaming Camp all
right he was going to grab food
[Music]
oh he's going to grab the food
you're trying to stop him is that Zach
got him
I got his name
this might sound crazy some of y'all but
this pickled radish is like my favorite
thing
I am dying for this pickled radish I
would do anything for this
stunning
okay moving on to this um
this is it this is bulgogi this is the
big one oh my God here it is
but what's bulgogi about this
it's me
not this most appetizing like
appearance-wise
I feel that I feel that
it does it I feel that big time
totally
um the goge is fine it was the same
exact flavor as the um galbi
which is that sweet Teriyaki but it's
good
Dan can I ask you something would you
eat lab grown meat
yeah
because that's coming apparently pretty
soon
that's pretty exciting for you
be interesting I wonder if you'll
introduce meat again to your diet like
as a staple
or at least occasionally
[Music]
okay
so that was the bulgogi geez there's a
lot of food here I'm full already kind
of
[Music]
full spread I'm going back for the
radish
[Music]
uh the literal translation of bulgogi is
fire meat fireman according to this one
random website am I crazy
[Music]
looks like a little squids
this is the um
glass noodle noodles made from starch
oh come on baby just one bite come on
dude come on doesn't we have this
come on dude don't don't come on man ah
damn
jeez Cami you know you're not supposed
to eat dude don't just so hungry dude
love gets all the food
don't worry about what love gets yeah
thing
cheers my dudes
[Music]
am I supposed to eat these just like
this I mean it's totally flavorless am I
supposed to dip it
I'd rather do something with these I
know a lot of glass noodles usually
comes in like a soup with bulgogi
sometimes
I just come it's like the most
flavorless thing I've ever eaten in my
life
what do you think of the texture though
it's fine I'll dip it into
the soup and see what happens
it's not the best noodle in the world
you know
I think we had a pretty good figured out
at flower
and rice frankly too sure
you know no no need to reinvent the
wheel
with the starch whatever the that
means
what does that mean rice water
uh
starch it's like it's flower starch I
don't know I know it's like a potato
[Music]
then it's rice
and so can we get it oh my God yo let's
put this aside what happened here
hold the thumb
kimchi
Boku mop
so if you don't like kimchi you're kind
of just sounds like
because that seems like pretty important
yeah this looks good though oh it's like
a kimchi rice
kimchi fried rice let's do this
right now dude
I guess I'm supposed to poke that
I don't have it I don't have the best
Chopstick skills for this seems like
high level stuff potentially
I'm not okay got it you got it oh you're
getting there
[Music]
I hate when um
runny elk gets like around my mouth it's
this most disgusting thing ever so I
have to eat very carefully because it
will ruin my day if I get it if it
touches my face at all
and in order to comprehend you're gonna
have to break some
comprehend in order to comprehend and to
eat the uh the omelets of knowledge
you're gonna need to break
those eggshells so does he like it or
not I can't talk I'll be honest I like
what's happening here but I have a weird
thing about raw eggs
if it's not cooked enough I just get
grossed out by it
so I think this is a good dish but
I can't say that no but I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna eat it just because of the
Raw
I like the runny yolk it's when there's
runny white that it could be it's too
Foods I'm not a fan of
and it's not because I'm homophobic or
anything
like I I totally fully acknowledge the
worthiness of gummy Foods it's just not
my forte
you know
do you like gummy Foods Dan
I have a problem
[Music]
oh what's this
Sam yeah it's called Sam
oh
Sam guy Tango
Jensen chicken soup
[Music]
beautiful that's the chewiest thing I've
ever eaten my God so long to eat it all
right
Sam Ki Tang a traditional Korean soup
typically eaten in the summer
chicken stuffed with rice ginseng root
and garlic and broth that sounds
terrific cheers
oh that's good that's very good
cheers
that flavor is delicious
but
I have to call you out but you're well
here let's take a look I mean it's the
white broth looks a little but
when you take a look at
it's a little that's okay see I
mean and that's okay I don't like you
know
we found it coming when I like mmm
chicken soft tender
Comey
[Music]
that broth is delicious
we love this broth don't we folks
this is the um
the Sam guy Tang
[Music]
is anyone watching this
yeah we got uh 43 000 people
[Music]
I'm literally just having lunch you guys
I'm just trying to disguise me having
lunch as a segment I'm sending Kevin
James memes if that
has anything
I said something wait let's make a Kevin
James movement out of this
me when I'm just having lunch but just
do it on a podcast live disguised as a
this is funny
they're making sure everything runs
smoothly for the member stream Ethan
why is this meme format so funny
oh an egg a hard-boiled egg thank you
Sam
those eggshells
breaking those eggshells
okay this is interesting
now
um chewy no chewy rice cake in a spicy
sauce oh that's what this is
a rice cake huh
it's called Duke Duke
Pokey
wait we figured this Duke bulky
too bulky
[Music]
um
such a trip
look at that soft luxurious inside oh
that sauce is good oh it's giving
this is very good
it's so soft and the I gotta say that
sauce is really good it's spicy
savory
not coming at all
then this is a little bit coming the
rice noodle or the rice cake
it's like a maybe a two on the scale
which isn't bad
this is barely and guys I don't think
about this at all
I rate every food I've ever eaten my
life on the scale it's more of one
to ten
um
this is really good
wow wow do bulky
hot and spicy I like it can you try this
Dan
I'm not sure which was fries no I don't
know what it might have been cooked with
have you had that before
I may have
it looks familiar
so this is just a hard-boiled egg I mean
I know I like hard-boiled eggs
take a look guys take a look it's not
like a century egg
um
I should have a lot I have a little
surprise
oh my God I tried one of those ones I
remember it's nobody actually
eats that right I think they're just for
gags
it's probably similar to the uh the fika
fish right
I prefer not to think about it I'm
making a bite of this what is it a
century egg yeah what is it I've never
heard it was it worse than the fika
fishy thing you never ate the fika fish
did you
you know I did I chewed a little bit of
it I didn't know what that was I just
looked it up actually like rotting egg
yeah is this a rotting egg it's so
gross is it worse
oh
frankly I can't even say that it's worse
Sam says it's not rotten it's preserved
the century egg thing gotcha preserve
them what ass
that could come
come
whoa what is this special little fancy
dread called Steve oh so you brought me
seafood at the end did you
Seafood scallion pancake it's every
pancake with green onions and assorted
Seafood oh come on Sam
you gotta try it at least
[Music]
you gonna be a big baby about it right
now I'm gonna try it not a lot of
enthusiasm though
I don't like this idea of assorted
Seafood it's like a so how assorted are
we talking
like I like fish
like what the is this like I don't
even know what the this is looks
like an oyster and it's raw and looking
in the middle I don't like this
this is weird
it's like an alien would you rate that
on the coming scale probably a three
it's still only three I mean it's pretty
solid yeah it's a three you're the
expert I'm cool to eating anything like
a four under right I can't try this I'm
sorry really I don't know what to say
all right dude I don't know what's in it
you don't know what's in a lot of your
food you eat hot dogs that's assorted I
know I know what's in the hot dog I mean
I don't know exactly well you can get an
idea there's probably it's beef yeah
this probably has various Crustaceans
various Crustaceans I care too much
about the ocean Dan
okay that's why I don't need it I'm not
yeah sure I want to I shouldn't be
encouraging you I mean this is just a
piece off the top which looks like
lobster or crab or something that's what
Caleb meant when he said bring up the
whole ocean
they uh chat a lot of people say they
like the century egg no no no no nobody
does I swear I'm seeing a lot of people
just saying that
ugh I don't like seafood man
just not it for me
it's like going to Mars and eating
martians I'm with you dude it's like you
find these weird little martian Critters
and then you're like let's barbecue them
and then maybe they taste good
so weird though
Century egg
um I truly don't believe that anybody
likes this
uh just looking at it
look at this dude
look at this one thousand
year old egg
it's not actually him no that's what
they called the century ago yeah
you're saying Americans don't have
Sentry Uggs okay I respect this car
we have a lot in China
Sentry eggs tastes good you guys should
give it a taste just try it oh my god
dude
oh
but you know it's very interesting
looking if you don't think about it as
food you're gonna need to break
iridescent almost eggshells the thing is
like and I know she's a cultural thing
so I'm not judging I just know it's not
something that I am used to seeing but
they eat the eggs
with the baby chick inside you know
about that yeah they take the baby chick
right before it hatches and then they
cook it and then eat it out of
it the hell
I uh I just made a uh
a poll in chat if anyone like Sentry
eggs and 79 so far say no
dude those one in five of our audience
members are down with these that seems
no they're just not possible I agree
dude I'm sorry in hot weather it takes
10 days or so oh that's not bad
that's quick
it's faster than uh 10 days that's quick
yeah I mean I'm disturbing probably in
there for a couple years
you can get it to look like that in 10
days
they even cook it huh
or they just cooking the sludge
yeah we like to cake it in raw sewage
get some cigarette Ash in there
that sick needs some Viagra thing that
thing was I think it was dear life man
oh oh interesting she says
this is a special occasion food for like
weddings and see that's what I meant by
like with the swim strawman it's uh they
like it it's like a special treat well
love always said that the the Boomers
claim they like the Tsum strawberry
with it yeah you keep changing it up you
say nobody actually eats this and
now you're saying Boomers yeah old Fox
no he always he was consistently always
said old older people in Sweden yeah and
also how old are we talking UH 60 plus
your dad like it nah
you said it was like Northern Swedish
specific too right like so we eat it
like during holidays like um some um
that's mostly it final one is this and
it's like a stir-fried squid it's like a
whole process right like uh the way of
preparing it you guys take it outside
and everything yeah yeah can I show you
look at this poor little squid this man
was just loving life lived love learning
his life
and I know I'm being a hypocrite because
I eat animals
but it makes it's easier for me to eat
the animal because
um it doesn't look like an animal
when I eat it
I need my like eat my uh you need that
layer of Separation yeah yeah right but
look at this sweet little this sweet
little squid he was loving his life he
was probably chilling with his mom and
dad and then what's this
Annette a giant net come to swoop me
away from my family and throw me in
boiled Oilers to some fat idiot
can talk about my dumb severed limb
on a podcast
he deserved better
it's probably grown on a farm to be
honest probably farmed it
there's almost no shot it was wild
Goose Family Farms I'm not gonna try it
I'm sorry it's just you won't even take
a little bite you take a bite I mean I
don't I don't eat that anymore when I
was a kid I love Seafood I used to eat
lots of seafood really I like squid and
octopus and all that stuff but fish
don't have feelings so you should be
able to eat fish that's what Kurt said
I'm not I mean I know I don't like squid
so what's the point
overall really nice I'll say this you're
into it
my favorites are this
[Applause]
dude number one
the goddamn pickled radish is insane
podcast
the all the beefs was were good this
ginseng chicken soup was very good shout
out to Sam on the Sam
oh
this tubes were very good
overall was a nice time I had a nice
time over here during my lunch break
so thank you
I don't know if it works it's good
I just like seeing you in his flannel it
works
do we have more of those because I could
I could just walk look at these memes
all day man
yeah oh yeah
we could just pull up Kevin James on
Google Images
I'm not even sure what's the joke but I
with it he's he's the Zordon
Zordon yeah yeah Zordon but did sword on
with the Rangers I'm not familiar
with the lore uh no he's uh no he's kind
of their leader in a way a spiritual
leader
um something up right thank you
he's just like he's just sheepish you
know he's just like did I do that
um
it's funny though
here's my new tattoo idea thank you to
uh bunny boy
hi sisters
apparently the the Kevin James meme has
become self-aware
like I guess he's using it to gain
Consciousness no no like
Kevin James himself hold on I think I
think it reached his Apec and what we
saw yesterday yeah he tweeted out
the sound I gotta pull that one out I
need that that closed the case on Kevin
James memes I'm glad you appreciated
that one as much as me I was saying the
more I looked at it the more it just
every every it hits on all cylinders you
know Kevin James tweeted this
you guys gotta look at this
Okay evan James this is a quote tweet of
Kevin James tweeting out check out my
friend's new movie The Sound of Freedom
now this is the right wing grips of Thon
movie about trafficking and then it
turns out
the Creator I mean I don't know if it's
his friend he's talking about but
a few of the top guys involved ended up
being like a straight Predators dude
yeah with kids one of them it was with
an underage girl yeah the other one they
were of age but he was still taking
advantage of people so then here's the
perfect meme check out my friend's new
movie The Sound of Freedom they aren't
any pedophiles involved in making of it
right
it's Kevin James that's literally him
oh that's crazy
why did you tweet that movie out Kevin
uh yeah he didn't specify what friends
uh maybe you know a friend of his has
had a minor role or something my friends
do the movie benefited out here I mean
maybe Rob Schneider guys there's a
disturbing image of Adam Sandler uh
circulating
we've now pinpointed two of his closest
friends are like Maga freaks Rob
Schneider and Kevin James he has to be
to tweet this movie Kevin James is he is
he dogs with uh yeah yeah Chuck and
Larry dude they're all blurred
okay yeah here here's a screenshot from
one of his latest
oh
we love her
and we hope she rests in peace now she's
in a better place like she's alive still
wait oh she's also died
so like
if he's keeping Rob Schneider and Kevin
James
what there's a good chance that that
Adams is going to be a Maga dude
uh could be yeah
um real quick uh just got a hundred
dollar Super Chat so can I get a super
chat for my good pal Dan bun Chuck and
the small pecker society as we embark on
our annual Retreat and then also my
girlfriend spreads Century egg on toast
not that I agree
that's is she Chinese or is that just
like some she got in she might be
or maybe she just really got into it
what is the live chat off damn
is the what is the live chat off my page
just bugged out yeah here it is wait
what what Sandler photo are you talking
about oh he we know he's friends with
Rob Schneider my best friends yeah okay
and we know he's friends with Kevin
James right and we know he performed at
the RNC convention in 2004.
bad news to me and he
well he had Giuliani in his movie but I
guess that was Prime contributed money
to giuliani's presidential campaign too
once again I'm not gonna hold that
against him yeah that was post 911
everyone had Juliana fever
we were feeling that boy we were feeling
him real good we looked past his
penguiness
but Kevin James
Kevin James and Adam
let's see
yeah these guys have done a shitload of
movies together they're even closer
besties than Rob Schneider potentially
I gotta admit I'm not
super familiar with the Adam Sandler
Universe what not really not since like
the 90s movies I mean I've seen nappy
Gilmore and all those obviously but like
all of these movies that he's pumped out
since like the mid-2000s I haven't seen
any of them I just know that these two
guys are tight
yeah I guess you're right they did yeah
Chuck and Larry then like grown-ups one
and two together yeah look at this man
all throughout the year never got around
to those
he's even got that face going here man
[Music]
you still got it that smug goofy silly
face
that's the King of Queens
yeah
so the concept of that movie was they
had to pretend to be gay guys to get
insurance correct to get insurance yeah
or Kevin James needed insurance man you
got to be real though these two guys are
right on the same level in terms of
fashion
well is this this is like a Premiere huh
my girl in the middle looks amazing yeah
she's slain we love her forever yeah
this is Hotel Transylvania 2. this is
the premiere
did they coordinate do you think looking
good I mean Sandler wears basketball
shorts on talk shows
look Kevin's the lip on his shoe is like
goes as high as a sock what shoe is that
looks photoshopped
you ever seen a lip down on top they
look like LeBrons Maybe
so Adam's mag I think
I hate to say it guys I think Adam hates
gay people
that I maybe maybe I took that too far
maybe that's not true
oh isn't he also a conservative Terry
Crews he's also kind of like a I don't
think so a bootstrap dude I think
I think he is
I remember that kind of came out
recently let me see Terry Crews
he got in like some hot water for saying
some uh oh he
hold on hold on hold on
he said something about defeating white
supremacy without white people create oh
something about
taking on white supremacy is creating
black Supremacy some really weird
premise
here it is
uh speaking out against black lives
matter I guess defeating white supremacy
without white people creates black
Supremacy equality is the truth
do you understand that
I guess he's saying without you know
um
incorporating white allies into the
fight for Black Liberation you instead
create black Supremacy which he is um
opposed to that's my interpretation of
that white supremacy without white
people well of course we're defeating
white supremacy without or wait no okay
this does not seem very like maggot to
me I I don't know I can see why he got
some Flack for it but
I think Terry's uh
Terry's all right we're gonna give him
the pass
I see somebody say Terry is cringe so we
we didn't consider that angle which is
more important do you think he's cringe
I I always thought he was sick
Terry Crews I can't say I'm super
familiar with either
that show's so good dude I know people
love it
uh I think I tried to give it a shot
once and it didn't really hook me so
apologies I know
I know it's got some Die Hard fans out
there you're not a 99 head not a nine
nine head oh listen to this quote listen
to this quote Terry Crews says
I don't have any political affiliation
but for the record MLK was a republican
yeah that was 2011.
just that's an interesting what yeah
oh this Suite has 60 likes not to
erase it's not too late to erase it I
had to check and make sure that early
Twitter baby
that's kind of a crazy take isn't it
uh I I maybe early in his life he was or
something I I don't know if that's
factually true or not
yeah I'm pretty sure that MLK is not
would not be affiliated with modern day
Republicans
yeah right even if he was uh
the official answer is neither very
infrequently talked about his personal
politics or not formally affiliated with
either political party
but for the record so never mind MLK is
Republican just saying kind of the same
he's kind of saying it
um
he invoked the Bible story okay now
that's an ultimate sin
yo he talked about King Solomon what
does this story look where are you like
pulling all these like
I just typed um Terry Crews conservative
gotcha and this is what came up
Terry Crews invokes King Solomon and
explaining controversial tweets from
2020.
I'm reading a CNN article saying that uh
MLK was a republican is a myth okay so
he even he even kind of ate the onion on
that one
he's hanging out with people who are
telling him that
but you know what
we're gonna give them the pass
we're gonna give him the pass someone in
chat named Adam Sandler said I cannot
disclose if I personally voted for Trump
or not
yeah we know we know Adam we know girl
so okay that was my my take on Korean
food thank you
very good
another stunning Terry Crews may or may
not be a republican no there we there it
is the Korean food segment
ah
what else we got here guys we gotta talk
about Taylor
we gotta talk about it let me set this
up a little bit because I personally
thought
that the Taylor Swift thing was not a
story it's like she's just got a new
boyfriend
and I was like I don't know about it
what a mistake that was well do we have
the screenshot of what Dan said because
I don't see it here and said you want it
hold on he's like actually this story
has a lot of legs I said the
because Dan as you guys know is the
PowerPoint slash uh Gossip hater thanks
amongst many other things he hates
uh so my the exact quote was because you
said is there really uh what's the story
uh her new boyfriend and I said there is
an astounding amount of information
about it
I was kidding I thought he's being
started no no and I said that because
earlier in the day I had seen
[Music]
Olivia's working document and I just saw
this wall of text and I was like holy
How can there be that much about
this but evidently there is but I'm I
didn't say that from a position of
knowing all the details I'm going to be
learning along with you Ethan well you
said basically though that you were
interested you were in
I was saying that we from Dan have a
show tomorrow we need something to talk
about so why might as well talk about
this Dan is in he's a queen he's a he's
a he's a caddy
right I'm helping you present yeah
that's what we talked about if you say
so absolutely I haven't present all of
it
I just go through it I could just fill
in the blanks yeah but I will do that
I'll I'll like leave some lines open for
you to finish okay and I'll hop in yeah
now here what are you seeing in the
comments this is a publicity stunt
we'll let
let anybody live their life
publicity stun and they can also have
crushes on each other that's Taylor
alone she doesn't need a boyfriend for a
publicity so she's the biggest thing
since uh kimchi Century eggs
right there you go I'm gonna say Hitler
which isn't why but he's huge right like
if you think about big things he's like
he's huge oh yeah Hitler was
clouded up like in terms of just like
geopolitical and uh uh influence and
just name recognition right obviously
it's not a real necessarily a compliment
to her but in terms of bigness like
what's bigger than that Heil Hitler
that is so up sound bite that was
not real that is crazy
do you want me to button
because yeah maybe you should yeah what
a slip up Psych
psych so anyway
um we stand Taylor
yes we love her we're gonna shake it off
here today
we sure are which is the title of one of
her hits one of her hit songs let's see
I'm just gonna pull up a list of her
hits so we can get some more puns in
here Taylor Swift hit songs I've got
them all Dana you're a 50. am I what
I was trying to think of a name for like
a Swifty for Hitler uh fans
guys we're gonna we're we're not gonna
be having a cruel summer
today no way because we are preparing a
great and this is a feel-good one too
yes and when I and when I saw that the
the the football player I knew I said I
know you were trouble yeah
right when you walk but nonetheless I
was enchanted
yeah
well you know it is a nice love story
that's it's a it's a love story all
right it's gorgeous as well yeah all too
well I know it all too well does the
story does this story have an anti-hero
hey it does actually I don't think so is
there any bad blood yes
and I'm so glad that um it's not August
because this really is a September type
of uh presentation yeah oh I can't wait
for me to watch this well I can't wait
for Olivia to reveal all the details
because you know they say that uh the
bestest
disinfectant is daylight true all right
go ahead and be Fearless in your
presence nailed it in Olivia
so let me let's open her up
is it just me or though she seems like
even more I know she's Mega
but it seems like she's having a moment
yeah right now okay
yeah she's in her errors era she
finished her first leg so
is she gonna have a post era era yeah
she's gonna keep going oh absolutely so
Taylor wow powerful image here
and Travis how old is Taylor
she's
33 maybe good for her man
uh she's yeah 33. oh I'm so smart I was
afraid I was afraid it'd be like 28 or
something or 25.
um Taylor and Travis the couple that is
uniting families across the country I
bet
I'll bet you a lot of people are are
talking a lot more at the dinner too
because I mean the worlds are colliding
that should never even be orbiting 100
right so
let's start with the players
um this player is Travis Kelsey he is
the football tight end you could say
that again for reals he's he plays for
the Kansas City Chiefs
um Taylor Swift plays for the world and
um she's Taylor Swift so he's a chief
because that's like the that's the big
team right now right they just won the
Super Bowl
or they were in the Super Bowl let me
check I think the chief just won Super
Bowl I get surprised every year when the
Super Bowl happens again it was yeah
yeah they're they're the big team right
now so he's probably a superstar yeah
lovely lovely moving on
um so one day Travis Kelsey was on his
podcast that he hosts with his brother
who also plays football in the NFL and
He was discussing his experience at the
Taylor Swift era's tour so this man this
masculine awesome enormous NFL player is
a Swifty yeah wow good for him I love
that I love that I agree I feel like
most dudes in that culture would be
embarrassed to admit that frankly I do
yeah it's also so interesting because it
just diversifies you from the rest of
your peers in a positive way so true it
really does allow yourself to enjoy
something
little football boys so here they are
and how long ago was this clip uh this
was in July oh so this is all happening
yeah it's all happening speaking of
Taylor Swift I know you went to the
Taylor Swift concert how was it yeah
well I was disappointed that she doesn't
talk before or after her shows because
she has to save her voice for the 44
songs that she sings so I was a little
butt hurt I didn't get to hand her one
of the bracelets I made for her if
you're up on uh Taylor Swift concerts
there are friendship bracelets and I
received a bunch of them being there but
I wanted to give Taylor Swift one with
my number on it now right now your
number's in 87 or your phone number you
know which one
she doesn't meet anybody or at least she
didn't want to meet me so I took a
personal she probably just hasn't gotten
over the Super Bowl yet she's a big
Eagles fan maybe she just made something
up and just didn't want to talk to you
damn it okay
so cute
a little presumptuous
I don't I I don't think so I think
that's him I'm a hunk look at me Taylor
should be down here getting my bracelets
no something about him being like she
didn't want to talk to people I wanted
to talk like the the fact that he's
still it's in Pursuit it feels sweet
still you think it's wholesome okay
so let's go back in time 2016.
there was an interview that came out
um where Travis is asked about uh it's a
f merry kill that game and he answered
that Taylor Swift would be his kiss
so he manifested this all those years
ago where is this here uh no do you want
to watch that clip I didn't I didn't
pull that one let me grab but he didn't
so he did KISS he didn't do kill Mary
yeah that's kiss where's kiss fit in
well he he it was with page six he kept
it he kept it polite
let me pull it up so which one is kiss
Mary
is kissing I assume I don't know
actually here Paige has never wanted to
kill somebody
Travis
[Music]
this is pressing maybe it was Kiss Mary
kill
kiss marry kill because
the is too vulgar the killing is
not
this was my ass kiss Mary snuff the
light out of their face uh manually with
your fists
all right we can move on it's fine I
have it yeah
all right here we go look at these two
huh page six it's all happening
Travis Kelsey admitted he wanted to kiss
Taylor Swift
[Music]
breaking news
kill marry kiss Taylor Swift would be
the kiss that was it wow that's breaking
wow
that is Yes man so that's why obviously
I included that part this page this page
entitled Travis Kelsey admitted he
wanted to kiss Taylor Swift in 2016
interviews everything thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
because Travis is a witch and I think
that's beautiful he manifested this for
himself
moving on next
the chief's Tick Tock page posted a
video where they asked their players
what their celebrity crushes were
growing up and around this time dumois
our girl had posted that Taylor Swift
was hanging out with an athlete and
there were already whispers about this
because he had been talking about her so
people were like Whispering about him so
you think they were already something
happening I think maybe like dming it at
least gosh I wonder how that happened
you think a DM you think he got her in
the DMS mate I I think Taylor probably
saw the clip of him actually I think
that Taylor hasn't caught wind of it yet
I'll tell you when in the story I think
in two slides I think that she he got
her attention but at this point whispers
are starting and like it's possible she
thinks he's cute but like nothing real
has happened to happen man this is
straight Blast from middle school
playground
is he do you think he's good I think she
probably like thought it was cute and
funny at first and then she was like oh
I'm interested
okay I'm liking it
all right let's watch
[Applause]
Oprah Oprah my man good
[Music]
Beyonce had me in the Topo
oh man she's tattooed right here on my
side yeah nice okay right here on my
side all right mine was Taylor Swift
[Music]
all right now oh Christina Aguilera Was
Won
[Music]
what do you say his friend said Taylor
Swift and he smirked and giggled and
then what okay
yeah
another huge breaking moment
it's deep deep what was it what is this
he did what is this
what what is this he did this when she
said when he said Taylor mustache I
don't know he had a mustache he shaved
it back now
I didn't see an article about his
mustache his hairline could be could be
nicer right here on my side all right
mine was Taylor Swift
[Music]
all right now is that a Taylor thing I
don't know what that is
smelling the finger no
do you
I don't know
all right all right
um then they were doing press his
brother said to the press that he uh has
seen the rumors and cannot comment and
then next slide comes the Royal
invitation oh what is that on the Pat
McAfee show Travis is asked about Taylor
and he says
threw it out there I threw the ball in
our court and you know I told her you
know maybe I've seen you rock the stage
in Arrowhead you might have to come see
me rocket stage in Arrowhead and see
which one's a little more lit so we'll
see uh we'll see what happens in the
near future
yeah
he invites her to a game people are like
okay
is she gonna go um
so are we sure there's even a romance
happening well at this point I mean
assuming things I was like they don't
know each other they obviously don't
know each other but then she showed up
to a game right and I was like oh I
guess something something cute is going
on okay okay so I opened my eyes a bit
you're invited to the royal game
but yeah it kind of uh that implies that
they've dm'd right because he said they
definitely talked yeah
see you Sunday maybe a text via you know
yeah
Taylor Swift is seen in a box with his
family and friends and it's adorable
so is she by herself she so as far as I
could tell I couldn't see her linked
with like a specific person in there it
was her and then just his family and
friends and he talked about how like all
his family and friends had wonderful
things to say about her so I don't know
if she was with any of her people
it didn't look like it very interesting
um
but I can see that maybe they're just
having she's just having fun with it
because everyone's been talking about it
yeah maybe maybe you know maybe there's
nothing happening yeah you can click
um there's a little clip of her at the
game on that was on the Jumbotron
uh what
you think Taylor likes football
no I don't think so either no shot do
you think she knows the the rules maybe
that's an American I think she probably
does yeah yeah
maybe she played it like Christmas or
Thanksgiving
[Music]
I mean all Americans know the rules of
football right I don't think I do she
said she was in the bleachers oh yeah
she wears short skirts yeah
I'm in the beaches she was wearing
sneakers on the bleachers
Swift and Donna oh look how besties they
are though I know so cute
um if you go back
um
back again
click watch there's a cute little
I see something cute is this cute so far
down
is this cute so far uh it's so cute okay
I gotta say the attention to detail from
these like t-channel investigations is
really amazing I mean if they were
around four years ago they could solve
the zodiac yeah definitely
yeah it's coming yeah right they didn't
mean to be there for it in the Box she
is there whatever that means
she will see what we hope she's a
fantastic contest most of you will get
that others to catch the Dallas Cowboys
in the Box beautiful that's pretty
baller she's sold out that whole stadium
oh yeah I have in a few I have like
stats of what happened after Taylor
Swift made her entrance into the NFL
I know that rule okay so we're skipping
we're loving it it's a touchdown loving
it there was a touchdown wait there's
videos of all this
did I just watch this one was it no you
didn't watch that one yet Jesus man
I mean I think oh that is very familiar
yeah they've meters
she just said she said something naughty
here
I mean I think no you can't say that in
2023 mama
you can't say that she said that Miss
Kelsey you're canceled she said I'm the
Zodiac
you're so canceled Mr Kelsey
man I think
I think the Secret's out who's she here
alrighty then touchdown so after Taylor
went to this game
Travis Kelsey's Jersey saw nearly a 400
spike in sales what yes holy um
this is just Taylor Swift fans yes
Kelsey's podcast now ranks number one
overall on Apple
um
Kelsey has added 383 000 Instagram
followers 24.3 million viewers watch uh
number one game of the week obviously
everyone too the Taylor Swift bump is
insane 63 jump in female viewers ages 18
to 49.
no kidding three times increase in Chief
searches on web three times increase in
Chief sales on StubHub and she sold more
tickets in a single day since the start
of their season dude the Chiefs could
better put her on payroll for real
that make her Kicker make Taylor kicker
I have to say as far as like fandoms go
I'm always like
it's it's shocking the the size and the
passion of her fandom is nuts man yeah
and it's all encompassing I see it's not
just like little girls I see like
serious ass
you know people you me or one of them of
course that's what I mean you bought a
Kelsey Jersey I've well yeah they're on
back order I got one I got five for each
one of us thank you so much for me no
not for you oh for me Ela Bruce Teddy
and Scotty oh I have to get my own
yeah they're rare they're hard to find
here I am this was just from this
morning
you look pretty good in the football
jersey I can't lie thanks bro you gotta
wear it more often thanks man put a
Patriots jersey thanks
uh here it is we're living in a world
where Travis Kelsey gets a tee down and
the cameraman pads to Taylor Swift
I'll mute it though yeah
T oh he scored okay we love that
I'll tell you who does love that
he says let's go is that what
she said yeah Chelsea
oh yes you did
she's loving being the football uh she's
loving being a football wife I think
it's super cute I think she's a football
wife love it and I don't mean that
derogatory she just likes being there I
agree
sometimes your husband plays football
and you're his wife
it's literally it's in the title what a
wild thing but she she's enjoying the
energy in that box yes
so cute little wingman Mahomes
um there was well actually the first
clip is
um everybody thought that it was him
looking at her in her box but there's no
shot that he could see her from the
field so I think they probably you just
don't know the power true love right his
eyes you can see better yeah you can
find her anywhere yes
um I think they probably put the clip of
her up on the Jumbotron and that's what
he was looking at and that's what people
were tweeting about but then the second
clip that you just pulled up now is
um Mahomes is waving towards where the
box is that Taylor and his mom are
sitting in yeah
with his girl in the Box oh yeah this is
all American as hell dude man I
wanna I wanna do the national anthem I
want to see an F-18 flyover right now
I'm ready to right now I'm ready to bomb
a village in a restaurant everybody
please rise hands on your heart let's
see some solutions Ethan
I mean apple pie I want an apple pie
right yeah
bomb them
so what Taylor was eating was so
important to the world to everybody
right yeah definitely I saw this it was
reported we spent an hour on food today
we can't criticize it's so important
Taylor at at in the Box she was seen
eating a piece of chicken with ketchup
and seemingly I'm not sure the siren
yeah red alert that's what I'm saying
these Swifty fans are they're on another
level huge news Fried Chicken maybe
Ranch she has One Singular Nuggie yes
these have not been dipped in yet
31.6 million views on this tweet what
kind of breading you think is on that
chicken I probably like panko yeah big
panko yeah Fancy with it surely not that
looks like good so I don't know what the
southern recipe calls for I think it's
just bread chicken
not panko Maybe
you want to keep things fun keep things
fresh with the pancakes but yeah it is
ranch and I think that's so good to know
about her like she really is just one of
us she really is just like no at the end
of the day
comforting to know it's comforting to
know
so because obviously that's huge that
she was eating that Heinz has come out
and actually I think officially they are
dropping ketchup and seemingly Ranch
okay let me say this Heinz she was not
eating this
okay together she's not the type to go
for this bottle
okay she's not a child can't she's a
grown ass she separates her condiments
that already exists yes
ketchup and seemingly Ranch well no it's
not not the name it's called a crayons
oh man why does kids super get oh dude
this guy dresses everybody how does he
do that okay so he looked really awesome
in this
that's what Eddie was wearing yeah
another another top tier podcaster Ethan
maybe you could learn something yeah I
got it so
this is the 1989 bedroom painting so
like Taylor Swift inspired denim set
from kid super it's called the 1989 yes
and it's adorable and he looks wonderful
wait is it actually inspired by Taylor
yeah it's called the 1989 bedroom
painting denim jacket what's that what's
the bedroom painting
it's on the jacket but is it about
Taylor Swift it's Taylor Swift inspired
denim set oh 1989 is one of her albums
right yeah and she's about to come out
with her Taylor's version of 1989. so
kids super is a Swifty
would seems so
I'm glad I didn't do research on
is he is do you think Olivia is he what
is he a hunk who kid super or no oh love
yeah I think he's super hot how tall is
he major hunkish
I honestly just think he's super hot
because he's so nice like he seems so
sweet to her
he's a little bad boy I mean look at
this he got the hardware yeah but he's
just like publicly pursuing her in a
very sweet and kind and I think
respectful way
um
what's his name again
uh Travis Kelsey wait I'm I'm seeing a
lot of feedback here they changed the
name after him after him oh my God so he
named a kid super set they they changed
the name after he wore it yeah I'm
seeing uh oh my God that's amazing
it's super what was it called 1989
before or no it sounds like no uh before
he wore I believe it's called bedroom
painting so now it's 1989 bedroom
painting yeah so what okay because I
found it on another website not the
official website where it's just called
bedroom painting there's a thousand
people saying in the chat so it's got it
okay so kid super saw it and they love
it I guess let me say this
Travis is six five what a helping Hunker
wow six five dude that's a unit where I
come from boy
I get lost in his arms probably he
probably tossed me around like a rag
doll
for sure
yeah let's watch this video
oh this is them leaving the game
together
so they were
not holding hands they had the shot
they're so but they're so together so
this is the end of the game yeah she
came down the locker room he showered he
changed he put on his drip
did he put on Mad drip for her yeah
drippy he's a little overdressed no a
little bit the pants matching the jacket
hmm
they all good together it looks like she
may have had her her hand her arm around
his arm
you know how you do like this the
girlies do like this they hook it yeah
it looks like that could have been
happening before they walked out I agree
with you
huge
we got a hey
okay I love stories like this that
literally Captivate the entire world for
for literally like two people leaving a
football game together it's brawling I
see this ending very badly you think so
wow all right
now we got a conversation Simpson like
what do you mean
[Laughter]
no Taylor look out all right Travis
loose um I see it ending very badly for
him what does that means for him why do
you say give me an example of ending
variable because it's gonna end and
she's gonna write a song about him and
now he's gonna be hated and he's gonna
revoke his so you're just from the
Chiefs you're referencing like the other
lawyer he's not gonna be commenting any
further no I'm not saying I'm
anti-taylor Swift I'm just saying this
is what's gonna happen this historically
this is what happened you're just you're
following the difference flow of History
he's different he I'm following suit
here also if he doesn't do anything
horrible to her she
I know what you're saying because it's
like when um
let's put let's make an example like the
peanut butter guy who the peanut
butter comes on the show right
everyone's like we love the peanut
butter guy but then we're like oh
he's actually a sexual predator yeah and
then we don't like the peanut butter God
so you when you play it when you play
with the fandom like that you know it's
nice one day and then all of a sudden
you're a sexual predator the next day
right like she's gonna write a song like
football field away or uh
heading downtown or with Trav or some
some type of double entender is gonna
I'm calling it I'm just saying I'm not
Auntie Taylor Swift so don't come for my
touch down you're fine I'm just saying
I'm it's not gonna end good wow I think
she'll write a song called I love you a
whole football field oh and I think
that'll be cute
when they're married no she's gonna
write a song called get him that's
what's gonna happen he's I'm telling you
he's gonna the Chiefs are gonna revoke
his contract she isn't vindictive wow
the Chiefs are gonna drop him he's life
will be ruined oh without a
doubt do you think he'll be death like
broke and homeless and drug addiction it
may be yeah
is
it's unbelievable well you better be
careful then they are magic you know
very careful it's true again in a sense
though it's almost impossible for at
some point for I feel like people not to
get mad at him for something
like all of a sudden he oh he left the
restaurant before her he didn't hold the
door open here's his address when you're
that up much under the under the
microscope right um this is a dress how
could you how could you know you know
okay I guess we'll we'll have to see
we'll be following closely dude very
interesting so what is this uh getaway
car so Taylor has a song called getaway
car they left in a getaway car together
look at this it's so high school my God
it's really cute
this is like 1960s this is crazy I just
want to say the chat are calling me
misogynist for saying that I think
that's that's pretty up
I don't think that's fair to call me a
misogynist for speaking my point here
yeah it's chill guys he's got a point
horseshit let the man speak like
um
Bobby says
right let him speak
well let them speak man
no I know where you're coming from Zach
I don't think it's misogynist they were
to say that I'm so that
pissed me off well you're going against
the swifties bro you got to be you gotta
you know what I mean I'm not though I
I'm I'm I did said nothing negative
about her I think there's a stereotype
about her that's like oh uh
she's no one can date her because she'll
just ruin their life like I feel like
the swifties are over that they they
want respect on their girl okay and
there's a little bit more of this and
she deserves respect just a little bit
more of this she's not only right about
love
Fair okay I don't I don't hate her I'm
just saying I think it's a little
far-fish exactly just a little more of
this
just wave and smile I'm just hey bro I'm
listen I want to back you up but I'm
just stepping aside right now ah okay
listen as a Swifty I can vouch for Zach
he's down I'm just stepping aside man so
Taylor and Travis were filmed leaving
the game together they headed to a
restaurant that Travis rented out for
Taylor him and his family and friends
and his team who's this girl so this is
his ex okay so her name
is Maya benberry and she spoke with the
daily mail yesterday and she publicly
warned Taylor she said Taylor seems like
such a fun girl with a beautiful spirit
so I wish her the best but I wouldn't be
a girls girl if I didn't advise her to
be smart it sounds better
just you wait only time will tell but
like the saying always goes one's a
cheater always oh man I dated in 2016.
apparently she's common for him however
Swifty's quickly noticed that she
literally liked a comment on her
Instagram that said on everything you
are and Travis gotta hold the L he
outside in public with frail gal Taylor
Swift who beside her Fame is a five bro
she's done yeah like you're not a girls
girl you like the comic Conor five oh
where does she live you think Taylor
Swift is
I feel no hope
[Music]
love that button
when your eye starts glancing over to
the button I know it to I know you know
I I said her address Maya and I took it
back right I think that was not whatever
it's a joke that's a joke that's a joke
of course I don't know where she lives
so what about the future for these two
but I'm sure some swifties do by now
um Travis a quote from him
was you know I brought all this
attention to me I did the whole
friendship bracelet thing told everyone
how butt hurt that I couldn't meet her
you miss 100 of the shots you don't take
what's real is that my personal life and
not uh what's real is that it is my
personal life and I want to respect both
of our Lives she's not into media like I
am doing the show every single week and
having fun during the NFL season on
other guys shows and any other show I go
on from here on out I'm enjoying life
and I sure as hell enjoyed this weekend
so everything moving forward me talking
about sports and saying all right nah
we'll have to be kind of where I keep it
Travis to his brother
so when everything moving forward I'm
talking about sports and saying all
right nah so he's saying Mom's the Word
on this trip on this side yeah he's
saying now now it's like he locked it up
yeah it does seem that way there was a
while we were doing this I saw that TMZ
released a photo of them at the party
together where her arm is around him and
it's just like kind of cute but yeah it
seems like it seems like there's a
little fling going on at the very least
here's the thing even if he doesn't do
anything wrong to go back to what Zach
said let's just say they decide hey
we're both so busy we don't see each
other a lot maybe he's just not gonna
work out and then there's probably going
to be some swifties that just look a
little too close into things and be like
oh he here's a picture of him with this
girl on this day nothing happened and
then all of a sudden people trying to
find out where he lives
literally
so I have a four question pop quiz just
for like the little drama heads like you
Dan thank you
yeah I'm ready I know it all immediately
will all hit me answer at the same time
okay I'm not gonna answer I think it's
cheating because I'm such a Swifty
you're such a big fan I'll stay out of
this bathroom go ahead
so first question if you go to the next
slide
oh no no oh
what team does Travis Kelsey play for uh
Chiefs yep you just said you were
playing I'm sorry I know I'm too good
all right I'm sorry then you just said
that answer I said wait to do this
picture
man all right let's just go to the next
question the Chiefs Dan did you know
that
he was on the Chiefs yet that's an easy
one come on that's a layout this is
mostly for Dan maybe right okay hit me
because he's super passionate about this
50s was that the only question I was
just messing around because you showed
it on screen all right well let's keep
going I'm ready
Chiefs got it
go to the next one what are the words
the public that we didn't talk about I
spotted Taylor in the crowd you didn't
mention that did you well I I we started
to watch the video but you clicked to
the next one what the is this damn
she said damn she's right there she's
right there oh wow
um okay what was Taylor's response to
his touchdown
now Dan was paying attention last one
easy what was Taylor eating
fried chicken with the ketchup
in the ranch easy seemingly Ranch
seemingly Ranch seemingly Ranch yeah
with some sort of traditional breading
yeah and then that's it okay
and okay all right so we did good let me
ask you this yeah
welcome to the Swift game
[Music]
where we are gonna test dance knowledge
uh-huh
on Swift trivia
that's right
I'm coming out with a question which
album
[Music]
is Taylor Swift's best-selling album
in fact it's also the best-selling album
ever released no that's not true no that
can't be true
that's I backed that up what is I back
out of that what is Taylor Swift's
best-selling album
Dan testing a Swifty knowledge what is
her best selling album
I mean obviously I don't know a lot of
them I I feel like there's a chance that
it's that 1989 one because I feel like
this is the one that I hear about the
most it's in 1989 released in 2014 it is
okay got it yeah real Swifty of course
to test your your uh
your merits here
okay Dan my question to you is this as
the resident
Swift head
of course
what is Taylor Swift's most listened to
song
what's the one that I've had to hear the
most in targets and
Starbucks
go ahead probably
um
what is Taylor Swift's it's probably
that we're never getting back together
one
I feel like no no no no no no that song
not our biggest okay well that was my
guess I guess I got one wrong I gotta
guess actually I'm a little confused I'm
trying to find the answer I'm not
go ahead Zach is it love story
it is not
um
let's shake it off
so yeah let's take it off that's a
better distance I'm getting we're
conflicting reports of Shake It Off
and
um
hold on and then this one
uh
if you want a real Swifty to chime in
here I guess go ahead baby what is it I
shake it off
yeah I'm not
are we sure about that I mean what
metric are we going by top listen to
Just most listens jacket Shake It Off
Travis Scott and Taylor Swift at the
chief game after party
oh damn what does that mean what is it
that mean that's cute
whoa what does that mean you guys that's
so me and the way the girl's looking in
the background that's so me this is us
right now this is me right now she you
know she's a sweetie
he doesn't know what's happening
how many views do you guys guess shake
it off as on YouTube seven billion
jillion you Cam you're gonna get
seven billion is it seven billion no
it's three billion oh okay good guess
though cam I was close
I have a question for anybody anybody
here what does a tight end do does
anybody know
s football I think they what's the
response I think they're the go right to
the QB they protect well tight end
tight end but he scored a goal so it's
got to be offensive
they asked Taylor Swift out on their
podcasts yeah I'll take that as a
correct answer I think he I think he
protects the they protect the QB on The
Running Place they
protect the quarterback but they can
also run it if they need to well they
are a wide receiver on passing place too
are you telling me because you know yeah
oh there you go so I guess I kind of had
it yeah you're Swifty football too so
they do both so they're really the most
talented people on the field probably
and cam who's the greatest tight end of
all time I don't know you tell me Gronk
that's right well I don't know okay baby
baby girl I don't know we talking baby
Gronk he's the biggest prospects of the
NFL I got a love-hate thing with chrome
he got rizzed up he raised up live he
died so Olivia dun raised him up let me
check
that's what I heard that's what I heard
that's just what I heard
let me see his salary he does 14 million
a year I guess that's pretty good
it's not bad that's almost crowd or
money
14. they're gonna have to pay him more
in the quiet now that he's oh yeah yeah
he's got that celebrity status now he
locked up a 60 million dollar contract
in 2022 that was pretty Swift they're
gonna have to double that yeah oh at
least
dude legit they're probably making so
much money from this though it's
actually insane
that that does that
she's modern day royalty she might she
could become queen of this country if
she wanted to
I think she could do a violent coup of
this country oh I think she's gonna yeah
have like a little Republic soon well
also this is really good for NFL views
because
I've Taylor Swift fans are going to be
tuning in like oh me on camera she
can be at the game you know there's a
question up in the air right yeah this
is huge for big Sports we got a trade
her to the Patriots that's all I care
about
this is everything happening right now
guys this is important stuff to know
about there it is Taylor Swift's new
boyfriend and chair definitely dating
you guys God thank you for going on
[Music]
uh let's see the writer strike is over
we love that apparently the the writers
took a fat dub dude pretty much
well I heard on the news today that like
Warner Brothers which was like the
biggest studio right now who did Barbie
lost like 600 million dollars from this
year alone from the
from the strike right so
pretty brutal but good for them yeah
they got everything the AI I finally
understand what the AI thing was because
I didn't understand what that meant they
just meant like feeding scripts into an
AI model and then asking the AI to make
movies based on these scripts right by
other people and one of the other kind
of nuanced things that they were worried
about is
the studio is using AI to write first
drafts of a script and then giving it to
a writer to punch up but then not paying
them yeah as the original author the
part of the deal that they got is a
studio they can do that you can have an
AI out a script and give it to a
real writer but at that point whatever
that writer writes that's now the
original product the the the first draft
that the AI made is worth nothing you
can't be like credited you can't pay the
writer less because of that anything
like that so that definitely is a
concern I mean right that'd be really
up
it's up for for on both sides of
it because they're using their scripts
to educate it
basically to replace them like them yeah
right
so good for them we love Riders
they got a pay increase improve benefits
the AI stuff
uh streaming compensation guarantees for
big hits
yeah that's the other B and that's the
other big thing is they got the studios
to agree to share confidential analytics
about how many views things are getting
which they weren't sharing which that
that's that's probably the single
biggest thing that they got to be honest
I was talking to a friend of mine who
does
shows on Netflix and I was like so how
many how many views did your show get
and he's like I don't know like even the
people that work there's a black hole
make the shows they don't tell them
how's that possible yep it's crazy total
black hole so they got them to agree the
the wga the the union will
be in charge of like mediating that
because I mean they they justifiably
have I mean that's confidential inside
information for them and they don't
necessarily want to share that with the
whole world
um but the writers should know damn yeah
with the people that you're paying based
on those metrics I feel like you have an
obligation to be transparent about what
that is I would love to know what those
numbers are I'm really curious yeah well
the reason they do hide it you know is
so that they don't have to give people
bonuses and that's like I mean that's
the only reason you would hide it that I
can think of seems like it yeah well I
mean I guess again they were claiming
that you know they want that to be
confidential for business reasons which
fine so now the wga can be you can give
it to them they'll be responsible for
keeping it confidential and they can
then share it with the writers
very good the people win again
power to the people
right guys
yeah we love power oh yeah we love the
people and we love power
I read actually there's some good stuff
on goose and gaps I skipped over this is
a ruderal head scratcher
and what y'all think about this
oh let me close out of this
um
here it is by the way speaking I heard
something about Taylor Swift and Justin
Bieber
I know that Taylor said like you gross
when she saw Justin but I read there was
another wrinkle to the story about why
Taylor doesn't like Justin that has
nothing to do with Selena scooter oh
yeah scooter that's what it was well
Justin also posted something when all of
that was happening in sappora of scooter
kind of saying like f off Taylor right
so that I I totally get yeah now what do
you guys think about this now keemstar
put out a really thought-provoking tweet
and frankly I had to stop and think
about it
Logan Paul of course he's having this
beef with Dylan danis
um obviously not really a beef I mean
you know Dylan danis is a psychopath
so he tweeted this photo he says she was
wisely Dylan pull out pay Logan 100 000
ruin reputation forever losing federal
court and declare bankruptcy or
fight and get ko'd by Logan suffer major
embarrassment make some money lose it
all in federal court
then keemstars put this forward he said
Logan Paul is more unlikable than me and
you know I it gave me pause
we hate keemstar it's interesting I mean
my distaste for Logan Paul
continues to marinate right it in fact
um
like a fine vintage it gets he gets
worse and worse as it you know you meld
the flavors together you understand the
cryptos the crypto scams with the uh
endangered turtles on the coast of you
know Costa or uh Puerto Rico Puerto Rico
and the flavors they meld like a
beautiful soup of hatred we love Puerto
so I actually wanted to throw the
question to you guys what do you guys
think in the comments
I'm talking to you guys though yeah well
like
keemstar first of all I think he gets at
least a small nod
for the acknowledgment that you know
he's a deeply deeply unlikable person
I agree with that
but like it's easy to overlook all the
crazy horrible keems done I mean
let's not forget
you know
what he did to Tony
but he said to a total biscuit I mean
these are unforgivable horrible things
he's done
Erica but he's been kind of laying low
recently I think
yeah I think that's something to
consider is that like
we're just not hearing about him anymore
so that's that's good he did he did a
good thing by disappearing I'm grateful
I gotta say though because I was
thinking about this a lot
Logan like he's done a lot of up
but it hasn't really brought me any
joy and keemstar has brought me so much
joy in my life like there's so much
funny that has come out of this man
that I cherish to be honest the sound
bites
that makes him more likable in your
opinion yeah yeah definitely yeah I mean
can you give me some keemstar sound
bites Zach some good ones
I hate keemstar okay Stars full Daddy
you're responsible for this
they're pretty good so frustrating yeah
oh yeah and then play me Logan Paul
sound bites
oh my God
these glasses have changed my life Macho
broken though let me tell you about
banana he is so obnoxious and then hit
me with the ding dong
[Music]
it's banger
the thing that really makes me pissed
off at Logan is like he's obviously
financially doing extremely well I mean
especially with prime the way it's doing
and yet he still will not pay back these
people he very openly blatantly scammed
yeah it's so weird and furthermore his
first reaction to Coffee Zilla was one
of the most psychotic things I've ever
seen
so I think keemstar has like a receding
effect like even though all the horrible
things he's done he's at least had the
good grace to like not do not be on
camera as much which is good you know
and then yeah Logan Paul he's been on
camera more
and still uh an obnoxious
right and I mean keemstar ruined a few
people's lives but Logan Paul probably
brought may have ruined many people's
lives with his scams people who invested
a lot of money yeah you don't hear the
story yeah perhaps less publicly but
right the pain is there interesting
well do you want to run a poll with our
audience yeah I do okay so who's more
unlikable Keem or Logan can you play the
Chernobyl Sound by Zach thank you I just
want the audience to remember
you know it also we got way more
enjoyment out of mom's basement than we
ever did from uh impulsive we got a lot
of
I miss mom's basement me too so I'm
gonna I'm gonna say it in a metaphor
right do you know uh like back in the
day like an old Russia there was that uh
nuke uh nuclear plant that blew up like
what's the name of that you know what
I'm talking about right
shovola or something something when that
thing blew up right like it was really
really like a lot of people died like
and anyhow I'm gonna tiptoe around this
because I want to say this so bad but it
might get cut out I don't know but there
is a much larger nuclear plant uh in the
Ukraine right now in Europe great and
there's fighting going on right there
and there's a live stream and there's
like a fire in the facility and they
said if it blows up it's gonna be like
10 times worse than the first one that
we were talking about yeah the United
Kingdom has just called for an emergency
meeting of the United Nations
like mainstream media so don't censor me
um uh he was very concerned about being
in security this is uh thank you Dad
this has turned into uh mom's basement
did end shortly after this I I should
point out no this was the last episode
oh
he was right they went shavola
on his ass if memory serves me this is
the last episode oh my God if that's
true that's wild I'll say this it's a
got him pretty close and keemstar's in
the lead he's ahead by six points but
I'll say this you know let's not forget
I mean someone said keemstar may be
responsible for a couple deaths
uh
more than one I could think of one but
is there more than one
of that Minecraft Youtuber oh yeah
that was Dean he was on faster
oh my god oh yeah like he died of covid
right but then yeah years later keemstar
like what was his tweet like yeah he
died of covid he moved Australia and
then he died of covet like the worst he
tweeted like something about like
there's like a cool down time before he
could talk about someone I believe I
thought he said it glad he's dead or
something it was long he didn't say that
straight up I mean he would for sure say
that he loves to do the Keem Shuffle as
I say
um so it's hard to say you know but I
guess the people really they still feel
passionate that keemstar is more
unlikable can't wait to report your
death I gotta say um
I know where you guys are coming from
but I'm still disappointed that it's not
closer because Logan really sucks it's
pretty close
I mean
58-42
I mean I guess nobody traditionally
would be able to hold a candle to
keemstar so the fact that it's even this
close is pretty astonishing
okay I
I may throw my my uh Viewpoint in here
keemstar gave us this
um
that's true there's just like a stock
sound effect though I understand that
but we took that up and I'm so happy
about that right can you play the stupid
piece of one today
when he called me a stupid piece of
stupid piece of this was epic
I don't know there's a dumb
maybe oh yeah it's dumb
baby
it's just so epic man like this day
specifically I remember being at the gym
and I'm training and I go in the car and
find out that he's been thinking that
I'm in his chat and his Twitter whatever
Twitter space going crazy just cussing
me out and I'm not even in there oh
there it is dumb Amy
all right well keemstar
we took your proposition seriously so
you should be relieved to know you gave
us pause and frankly it was it was very
close so I guess keep laying low
yeah a couple more years and maybe yeah
maybe Logan will take over one or two
more scams by Logan a couple more
cadavers you know playing with dead
animals bodies you never know leaving
your pig into out and to die in the wild
um these are all good things
trampling uh protected
turtle eggs with a ATV
these are all good things
right
and we love him for those these things
[Music]
um
a crane smashed him in the head
yeah
I just saw this on the subreddit and
it's the most Italian clip of all time I
don't know what it is
the goofy felt the Goof fellas no you
just turn it down
what was that tell me about it these
Italians I tell you man
they're good people they're good kids
you know what I mean a green
smash the mind is that dude that guy's a
good fellow what was that accent
a green Smith Henry
there's a face we haven't seen in a
minute a Nook just dropped a spicy new
hug oh that's right yeah our boy yeah
voice of God actually it's more of a
rendition
who the is that dish
nose
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
Merry Christmas okay so I was confused
everybody because he's doing chestnuts
but he's showing Curry dude I gotta
stand up for that girl in the car it's
so Boston
you you know that looks that tastes good
I think that's like the golden Curry
yeah it's really awesome
is this a date proposal I feel like
perhaps a romantic
romantic offer to any ladies out there
maybe because he is very his whole thing
is kind of like Suave
you know
very seductive
so I guess maybe it's an invitation for
curry for two
Britney Spears is doing great she's
doing just fine everybody
she's out of the um conservatorship and
she is doing just fine
in fact some would say
she's better than ever
[Music]
he's going off with these times
she's doing well and we're all happy to
see it
those dogs have to scatter they should
definitely step back
um the caption says it's not real lives
but those are real knives you can hear
clinging them right
also she's doing ching ching ching she's
like a Hibachi chef I don't know if
anybody else has said this but she
posted something afterwards
sauns the knives and she has a bandage
on her right arm and I'm pretty positive
a scratch on her thigh yeah I saw that
she cut herself yeah she's like actively
bleeding yes and she's like let me take
another one yeah she's feeling extra
inspired right now oh she's back to
Fruit Ninja sounds killing me like she's
we've got to do an edit a fruit ninja
edit
slicing all the fruit
that sounds good
live sound designer
no but I'm happy to see her doing well
and we love a free we love a free
Brittany
um
absolutely
here she is with a scar on her leg
is this the one
this is the one right after four second
slide
this one nope that's when you're just on
second slide
second slide of this yeah
all right let's see
is it arrow to the second slide second
it's it's a slide it's like a gallery no
I did the arrow oh I guess I just yeah
that one no the one you're on initially
okay let's go back we're gonna click
yeah there it is yeah yeah so she has a
cut on her thigh and yeah and a bandage
on she has a bandage somewhere else on
the right hand on her right arm we love
that girl you because you served yeah
she played
[Music]
you know I like Hibachi and girl you
served
so um
huh
so right freedom and she just got a
divorce too right from that guy yeah was
he bad news what was the story then a
lot of people thought that he was bad
news some people thought that maybe he
knew the like was talking with the
family I don't know oh no not that
that's that's too much of a betrayal I'd
be out there dancing with knives too it
doesn't seem
landed on good
Ariana Grande spotted at Disneyland with
her new stolen boyfriend SpongeBob bro
it's horrible
so they're taking the show on the road
they're on tour
all right well at least they're giving
it a good shot I mean they you know and
that's that's the least they could do
after they ruined two families for
nothing
or one family I don't know
this is it
that's all we get
it how do they even know that's them I
could tell him from the best I'm so
up
to be parading him around
well they're gonna try to be together so
what other what option does she have I
mean maybe I I literally can't believe
that this is real I just she's a bad
person I guess I mean like I don't know
they're gonna be the first no sure it
was pop star
hold on one sec um
as we talk about this I do want a pepper
the ambience here a little bit
uh oh
the atmospherics here
with um
what's his name Ethan Slater
I mean like if she just dumped him and
ruined his family that'd be
that'd be even crazier so I guess they
gotta try to like make it work at least
for for like a month or two for Optics
you know what I mean
you know oh my God yo you all every man
out there around the world
to all the ultimate Gentlemens
to all the men going their own way and
everyone in between the ultimate
gentleman's
that's the uh yeah I know yeah
this man here there he is
SpongeBob
I love how we have SpongeBob's teeth oh
yeah just is SpongeBob it's good casting
computer man wonderful
open image and new in new tab there it
is there's the one
such a good call very good call
this man
grab one of the most desirable women in
the world
color would you say his eyes are hazel
easy because he's that much of a nah
he's brown eyed shut up you're not
special Ethan Slayer
that's right
yo who has beautiful eyes his ex-wife
stunning eyes oh no but like like
genuinely what's your excuse guys yeah
yeah get out there all you got to do is
go be a leader in a musical Broadway
performance yeah I mean incredibly
talented singer not that hard not for a
Tony easy
he did
um
destroy his whole family life I see a I
love him he's so hot and all cap in the
chat
so yes there's at least one admirer out
there yes
Ian's the only hot Slater I know
I would have kissed him I'm being honest
really before he was a horrible guy
right you would have kissed him you said
he was a super talented guy SpongeBob
with a recently born child he were a
kind person with that much talent and he
was interested sure I'd kiss him right
okay he would look past his absolutely
heinous exterior right right and it's
just my ass and as uh P Jones in the
chat just
put it uh has that theater kid glaze he
does yeah
Broadway glaze
he does have a glaze
yeah a lot of people are pointing it out
in the chat the glaze yeah is he Mormon
oh I don't know about that I'd like to I
mean it's worth asking probably he's
worth asking
I mean I know the glaze when I see one
he looks like very young isn't he
[Music]
yeah right
not James Charles type no no too old for
that he's 31. 31. he's uh Jewish I'm
saying oh come on man Jewish
get that out of here he's Jewish
that's what the Jewish Chronicle says
you know what he's got he's got that
Blues Clues glaze
like Steve Steve's a go though
oh yeah and freckles freckles are kind
of wait he's Jewish
yeah that's what we've just learned
Jewish descent it says he's of Jewish
descent does that mean yeah I'm 100
over here what's yours right yeah how
much descent what by a percentage right
exactly because like I'm I'm of Jewish
descent
so that's it I guess that's pretty much
it huh that's it
so tomorrow is leftovers yeah I will
okay let me let me ask you I have a few
more questions
can we just like take one week off
it well I wasn't planning on it being
more than just a few minute cars it
won't go there that's the question I
have some questions Dan about capital
and the socialist society I think
capital is
well I don't understand the logistics of
it frankly
I'm not sure what you mean
should I ask you these questions check
EBT
yeah ask your boy let me ask you ask
your boy just uh what I it did I'm not
sure I understand the context that
you're you're asking so it seems that in
socialism
the idea of
Capital the money holders uh-huh it
seems to be seen that's not exactly how
a socialist would Define what capital is
though just a
okay the manual people there's people
with money and they invest the money
right
or just there's no money in your Society
no it's not that it's not money money
would be a form of capital but it would
be it would be a lot broader than that
so let me ask you this though so let's
say there's a business we're making
chairs
one dude is like I want to make this
business making shares but I don't have
any money
or no no even different the owner the
guy who established it he takes a loan
of a million dollars to make this chair
company okay
and then over the next five years
he hires 20 people
and they're all making chairs together
so now these people these 20 people are
part of this
uh Collective Democratic workplace right
and so
when let's say he gets sued because
um let's say somebody got injured from
one of the chairs or maybe there's some
copyright infringement and then they go
uh they go we're suing you
the guy who made this company and put in
the million dollars for five million
dollars we're going to destroy you
financially actually and and let's fast
forward he loses he's financially ruined
so do his workers share in that uh part
or do they just get to bail and Go part
be a part of another Co-op while this
guy's life gets ruined well there's a
few clarifying questions with the
scenario that you're laying out is the
loan that he took out a personal loan
it's a business loan right so that the
businesses owes that money not him
personally
well that's well it's just alone that's
there are copyright actually goes
through the Corp the S Corp it's weird
up there's a lot of things that
can penetrate the corporate veil
interesting
well copyright isn't something that is
necessarily well maybe it's a specific
well just just play with my example do
the workers right do they
um participate in the liabilities or do
they just enjoy the benefits of the
capital this guy who took all this risk
I mean listen this is something that
came up a lot the other day when you
guys were talking about it but it's just
like there there is no there's no
Doctrine here it I guess it the answer
as always is it depends on how things
were set up what was the agreement when
those people got brought in if they got
an ownership stake in the company as
part of like them coming into the
company then then no they would also be
available just as much right so they're
been so they're taking they're taking
benefit from the the growth the profits
all the upsides of running a business
but when it comes time to pay to uh get
sued and to have some serious
liabilities it seems like they get they
get to get out of that and I I don't
quite understand how that you just
talked right past what I just said I
hear what you're saying but I don't
think so you're saying every single
business in the whole society's Society
is set up in one unique way like no of
course not and that's what you guys you
guys will never give me specifics you'll
never tell me like there needs to I just
gave you I just gave you an answer and
you just talked right past it yes it did
oh say it again
when you said it's complicated that's
all you said I said I yeah I said it
would depend on the circumstances you
you said this guy starts a company and
then he starts bringing in other
employees and he shares ownership with
them so when they get sued yep no they
would not Escape liability it would be
shared amongst them okay
yeah
great that sounds horrible for the
workers I gotta join a company and
accept liability for the owner that's
correct well again it would who wants to
do that I'm switching teams somebody
that webcam's not getting from
somebody that wants ownership stake in
the company but no who wait it doesn't
have a choice that's how the workplace
is organized
I I it should be clear I mean if we're
if we're gonna do this it is so clear
all right you know what I don't want to
talk to you about this every workplace
is set up differently it doesn't make
any sense
I guess you're right
right
dude I'm not
I just I really don't want to talk to
you about this with you
not interested in having a conversation
I'm just trying to understand it because
I still don't
you know there's this discounting of
capital like it's like doesn't mean
anything but it it does I mean
ultimately in the real word there's huge
risks dude with putting up money for
Stuff
and socialists don't want to acknowledge
that it seems like unless I miss a Miss
I unless I'm
misunderstanding it
I'm not talking over to anybody
I just think if we just put Taylor Swift
in charge of this country would be okay
I think so too thank you Ethan you're
accepting liability because you're also
ownership stake right right now I
control who has the ownership of it but
in this workplace people would come in
and get some level of ownership for
literally no liability it doesn't make
any sense to me it doesn't make sense to
me listen I want this Society to work
that's why I'm asking these questions
right thank you
so should I ask him about it or no Dan
it's your show
all right
it's our show
no it's not
real
all right guys
Kill The Vibes real fast here I told you
I didn't want to talk about it well well
you entertained it and then when you
said you didn't want to talk about it I
stopped yeah
true not to forcing you into a
conversation but anyway here's me right
now uh here's Capital owners and
Associates Society
okay
that face when you're a capital when you
own capital
um thank you guys for watching
we will see you guys tomorrow which is
the time and place
Ethan actively ignoring and bowling his
employees about employees
yes I'm bullying Dan
I'm actively bullying Dan
um thank you everybody so tomorrow I'll
ask your son I mean you know that's the
spot to do it right
you guys want to hear my questions hear
that song can prepare
so that's my one about like if a company
gets fined or loses a lawsuit what if
the company operates at a loss there's a
lot of companies that operate at losses
so you start a company and this is
commonplace and they'll run where their
operating costs are in the negative
Millions every year so how is an
employee supposed to get paid do they
pay like
how do they make money
yep thank you
like Spotify
they've never profited ever I mean
Google just started Pro or YouTube
started property for the first time like
a few a couple like a few years ago yeah
I mean it's very common
I feel like it's a good question
I'm not I'm not pointing this to you Dan
at all I'm just putting it out there
um
what about if you default on the death
the capital owner can lose his
house
you know what I mean
are my employ are my co employees gonna
lose their house and their cars
I don't think so but maybe they want to
you know what I mean
I got big questions boy I got big
thoughts
I'm the most hardcore socialist there is
I just want to make it work that's why
I'm asking these questions guys I'm
ready bring on the Utopia
that's right
having a big diverse
conversation right now
we're having a really productive
dialogue here on socialism
just me bouncing around the screen oh
yeah
yeah that's right
wait one more thing no I'm kidding all
right see you guys tomorrow at 10 for
leftovers love you all thank you guys so
much
[Music]